you
and i'm so sorry
i cannot sleep i cannot dream tonight
and
with you and always
is it
live yes always
hey guys we're live
we're live we know
hey riley are we live i don't know
they just said it into their ears yeah
now they know what's going on why are
are you guys both uh
sexually angry right now are you
aggravated i mean what were the
guidelines you wanted to put down no i
was just mad because um
han shat in my ear and it hurt so sound
check
it well it's not a shout check i wasn't
shouting that's just how i talk when i'm
getting animated
so we need to make sure that
surprising to me
and that's okay you know we're over it
now
are you guys
you should get the mic closer i actually
didn't think that he was that mad
i thought you were kidding me no i was i
was mad no they were mad that was
genuine you didn't feel it that was
genuine anger
a little closer i was like riley out of
10 is like me at a three
i've never even seen you get that are
you bragging about how mad you get why
didn't why don't you get that mad
anymore i just don't get angry why waste
time getting angry
so did you mellow out with age you just
said yeah i wouldn't even say i got like
i never like an anger
management problem i just don't like
i'm pretty
not angry now though
yeah i feel like as a kid i got a lot
really angry a lot more because i didn't
have any control
of the world i was living in
i feel like i'm angrier now
i would agree with that
yeah i've lived with justin for six
months and he's angrier than when i
first moved that might be me
it was a lot of anger i mean you know
why you know the reasons why i'm angry
and then nothing changes so you know why
oh this is a problem with angers it just
compounds on itself see and he's like oh
i don't even know what you're talking
about he knows exactly what the [ __ ]
he's talking about you leave it messy
yes i'm messy messy as [ __ ]
but uh one of the messiest people i've
ever lived with three people live in a
one bedroom no
you were gone you were when you were
gone guess what the place was clean
well did you guys like have this
discussion before you moved in
when justin was gone people came over i
think you have really high standards
justin no i don't i think you do no i
think that i think it's disgusting it's
like how some people can leave [ __ ] and
just like leave a mess and it's like how
what
what are you doing you animals but to
you what is just like a little bit of
christmas i agree like you should not
have a little bit of crumbs yeah that's
fine but if you leave a little bit of
crumbs guess what you keep leaving a
little bit of crumbs it becomes a lot of
crumbs so every little thing becomes a
huge thing because it can lead to a
bigger thing yeah because no one stops
the little things which the place could
stay easily fine if you just clean up
your little just gives you an excuse to
get mad at every little thing that
happens
no i don't want an excuse to get mad
slippery slope of of angry crumbs
yeah
it's i don't like to clean up after
people and i have to do that
would you like to you would hate hansel
and gretel
why
say leave a lot of good ones riley
oh yeah but um yeah i mean
this is uh off to a good start yeah it
is
how you interrupt yourself right now
um
let's just make puns anger is
we're talking about anger today we're
talking about anger anger is fun
um
i mean it's tough to stay with anyone
for a while you find little things that
you don't like and then they don't fix
it and then you take that personally
um
and like the little idiosyncrasies
become bigger and bigger i can stand
anyone for a day i mean i stood that old
haggard lady from yesterday for like a
night she stood you up actually yeah she
actually said i've had enough and i'm
abandoning you she left you i could
withstand
her for a day i could withstand anyone
but as if you stay longer then it's just
it's just more difficult because then
you play meta games and then you don't
have any stamina for defense dude i
didn't even meet her and i didn't want
to be around her for
like ten years she was an awful person
she hates me she hated me right away
yeah why she hated me last night what
did you do riley didn't you say like hey
nice tits or something to her
i mean you're like hey [ __ ] nice tits
and i was like right that's probably not
yeah i mean but i don't know why that
would anger someone that's true you're
just complimenting her right yeah that's
just how i just said hi to i was just
like hey i i don't know i didn't even
address her really wait so you're saying
what i said didn't happen
no yeah it didn't so you didn't go up
here and go hey [ __ ] nice hits i
thought about it but no
i mean she had that cocaine eye or
one eye flutters
like
she can't open her eyes all the way
which i thought was something we had in
common
she said she had a stroke
she did have a straight stroke she told
me she can't do flashing lights
why
because it'll give her another stroke
why'd you go to an arcade then exactly
or she's a liar
they just [ __ ] they need buzzing
lights and they just need cheap
stimulation they can provide their own
fun so they have to go somewhere where
people are having fun so they can be
around them people with strokes
what people who have suffered strokes no
people like her who are
really not that fun or
smart
i would say what games did you play
pinball
shooting game a racing game mario kart
her favorite game was leave the asian at
the same game
what games did she play with you
she played the game of is that why you
wanted to watch those trying to have sex
with me youtube videos of people finding
where they were
oh you got geoattacking you got home
next time
not again
yeah that's useful
yeah yeah what the what was that that
you guys put on last night geoguessing
geo guessing yeah and it's like a big
thing
it's not a big thing
it's a website you can play it
yeah it's pretty fun how did you guys
find that dude what if one of the things
that's just like us in our garage
it turned it on like twitch i'm sure or
something like that
i honestly i honestly have no idea where
we are right now
first texas and i've been here for like
two days
yeah i don't know it's like really close
to fort worth and i used to live here
and i don't know where we are yeah
really yeah how long did you live here
for like six months well i guess this is
technically bedford i don't know where
we are really
dallas is not designed well a lot of
neighborhoods are split
it's just an infuriating place to live
why is it infuriating because you have
to drive everywhere everything's spread
out takes a lot of gas
you can't walk anywhere
yeah it's noisy it's polluted yeah i
would not you really can't walk anywhere
maybe if you lived in downtown dallas
but even then
yeah i don't know what you're really
walking to i guess if you position
yourself in the place like walk to your
job
yeah the mics here are at least 20 to 30
minutes spread apart so you're doing a
lot of driving and you're not like and
there's no lime screws with other people
you can't lime anywhere really because
it's all too far there's no point of
having a scooter
the scooter's gonna be like 23 to get to
the next
thing
because it costs that's how much it
costs for like a razor scooter yeah
austin really is spoilers
austin really is because i don't want to
go like
10 minutes away i never did the lime do
you guys lie only if i park like a like
ten blocks away or something yeah ten
blocks i'll do yeah i never even do that
like i always find my you know what
pisses me off sixth street can get
pretty busy yeah especially now like
schools
getting towards like finals again it's
getting worried really bad it's annoying
to take the lime scooter downtown i did
it the other day at firebase
is in his lime season yeah i was so far
away but then you drive the scooter to
where you need to go downtown and you
can't park the scooter downtown because
it's an unsafe zone to park it so then
you have to drive again farther away so
it's not even a point taking the [ __ ]
lime anymore oh yeah there's some zones
that just like it like yeah it takes off
yeah it's like you can't no you can't
park here and you're like where the [ __ ]
i'm supposed to get yeah oh i gotta park
back where i and the whole point of
having a lab scooter is that you don't
have to park you don't have to find a
parking spot yeah no you just set it in
front of the building
thursday through sunday they have a
blocked off zone because it's not safe
because there's drunk people walking
around
and they don't want to run into them
yeah there's drunk people also online
scooters yeah they're only drunk people
those drunk people are going 30 miles
per hour
on a lime scooter across
into heavy traffic that's way worse than
driving a car because you're already
outside the car with no helmet yeah but
you got all the alcohol in your body so
you're nice and nice and limber if you
get hit you're kind of just let it
happen
you know you're supposed to be free
you're not supposed to clench it
actually yeah that's why the drunk
driver survived yeah there's everything
clenching up helps
so we're talking about this kid who like
took xanax and alcohol and fell off a
building and survived because you're so
limp dude that was so chill
yeah did i just fail dude and i was like
i hit the ground and i stopped it it was
chill
i'm not worried about it he wasn't
worried about it at all when it happened
he's like the reason why he is no he's
definitely
he still broke up a bunch of bones
and like pretty much got really [ __ ]
up but
like he didn't die because his body was
like
somewhat limp is he not paralyzed
i don't think so i don't know i just
said who told me this is one of your
friends
it's like one of my friends that he knew
you just don't hear about the times
where you tense up and it helps you no
because that's expected well yeah i
don't i don't know if that would ever
help you yes it does if you're a shield
then your bones aren't taking all that
weight some of your muscles is taking it
too
yeah yeah like if like what if something
is trying to trick you
your body can move certain ways that it
wouldn't if it's tense so if your neck
like needs to go this in your tense it
might
i think right well your muscles are
holding it so if the force is larger
than your muscle then it's going to go
that way anyways and hopefully your
muscles can
save you a little bit of degrees of
angles also friction like tensing up for
friction
i mean your body isn't just going to
tense up for no reason it probably does
it for survival or else it would have
been naturally selected out
yeah okay that makes sense right it
seems like the times when your body's
limp in an accident are like
freaking naked sometimes my body is like
really tense while i'm like trying to
[ __ ] take a nap
like
that's called a boner
no
you wake up tense
uh where like sometimes your body is
like tense where it like are like i
don't know if you're just like tense
you're not like tensed up
yeah and where it's like you're not you
don't want to be tense right now it's
not like your body's in fight or flight
bad yeah
you're having a nightmare dude
no
what you guys don't know what i'm
talking about no i wasn't trying to go
to
when you have like when your body's
tensed up that's like an expression
yeah because you're having a nightmare
you're scared
not a nightmare or stress yeah stress
money women most likely probably
no one will [ __ ] me and he's like oh
he wakes up
i need to get a new car dude no way no
one wants to [ __ ] me it's not chill i'm
just stressed out about how tense i get
and then that makes me more tense it's
like a never-ending [ __ ] it's a loop
of tenseness
it's like really intense
you start tensing and then you just
can't stop it's a cyclical
loop if you even have a little bit of
tension it's like leaving a crumb out on
the counter
for justin
just keeps
keeps cycling over and over higher and
higher
until you just burst it's like the
feather and forrest gump
okay i never saw that movie you've never
seen them
well how is that a joke because
everyone's seen it i feel like i feel
like forrest gump is your father riley
is you know is he oh oh oh you mean he
is is he small you mean an american hero
oh can he can does that mean that he
you're not an american hero your dad's
forrest gump so i'm also saying you're
[ __ ]
he's an american hero
he's not real he's done so much for
society
you're touching a sore spot except
except make a good son you know jesus
whoa dude i bet his son was not even
his his son was haley joe smith
uh he went on to have a successful movie
and now he saw it and now he sees dead
things
oh [ __ ] that's the same kid same kid oh
secondhand lion that's probably they
probably have something to do with each
other is it is they didn't do that movie
a.i
he kind of fell out creepy robert did
like entourage he does like little roles
in some terrifying movies
i think he was in the entourage movie
too i remember like the flesh
when i was like maybe like eight years
old
and then like just the aesthetic of that
movie is terrifying
there's a pool scene i don't know what
happens during that place oh yeah he
falls into the pool and it's just i just
remember like it's really colorful but
it's everything that's going on is just
dystopian nightmare ai
it's suburban nightmare who who directed
it in the pool it's the stanley
cup spielberg
i prefer a e
steven spielberg there's like some crazy
story behind that i prefer a and e i
prefer i like that network it's a good
network i don't know about ai i know
about a.a
yeah i know about n.a
and all right problem really we should
like really fund the nra i'm serious you
guys
yeah
for who's saying let's be serious
let's be serious let's have a serious
podcast
let's fund the nra and give them all
right all right let's all put that's all
like speeches all right whoever donates
the most money to the nra gets like
i don't know you get an air 15.
do you think kyle you get to kill
someone do you think they're going to
make him the face of the nra pat
rittenhouse he's going to be on the
magazine cover he's going to be a hero
he's going to be on time magazine
national hero i mean he's a whiz kid i
think he's an island killed two kids
before he turned 18. look what he's
doing
now he's managing your 7-eleven he got
two legal kills before he joined the
military he said he wants to be a nurse
dude but imagine like that's [ __ ]
every single one of his resumes from now
on did you see him [ __ ] did you see
him beat up that girl
he beat up a girl yeah he was trying to
well she probably threatened him
she was attacking his friend and so he
goes up behind her and smacks her
it starts punching her like it's the ufc
this kid is just looking for drama
girlfriend
no just some random girl
they were fighting and he's like oh
she's yeah maybe it's his girlfriend
dude he has a right
but uh he just loves drama he just loves
being in the thick of like
drama dude i think he just likes killing
he's like a glee kid i'm pretty sure
improv totally
that'll that was just yes ending that's
what improv will do
i see you protesting and i'll protest on
my own too
and oh [ __ ] i'll bring a gun okay he's
more like a gun he's more like a yes
skateboard and i raise you
yes there's shots in the body dude i
have an ar-15 he yes ended the
yeah you're not supposed to say no
yeah
why can't you say that's such a stupid
rule i feel like for improv you can't
say no
but if maybe if you make the scenario
into like something better like if
someone is just like supposed to make it
if someone is just like oh you're like a
uh
a giant
[ __ ] right yeah just like what and then
you're like yeah i am
yeah and then you make it into something
yeah dude that sounds right that's me
and these are my this is you need a yes
and more yeah maybe see how great that
was it was good but then you're just
like [ __ ] for a second dude yeah i
guess it's kind of just like taking like
other people's shitty disgusting stop it
opinion stop it yeah stop build
something together if you're just doing
it on your own then what's the point of
having other people there
yeah i guess i'm like coming at the mind
of a stand-up comedian yeah dude you're
not really in problem why don't you just
stand there alone and recite jokes you
already writ
written wrote wrote writ what do you
have to do yes you have to make it up
on the spot don't move the mic stand
when you get on stage
hey also
don't don't be funny
yeah i mean i i have seen a lit see
that's the thing i've seen a lot of
improv that's not funny yes i mean i've
also seen a lot of people they've all
seen improv
yes and i have seen improv too
yes and i have seen yeah i guess it just
depends if the people are funny or not
that's really at all i've seen yes and i
couldn't agree what is funny i find
funny to be a religious thing like oh i
can deem you are funny or not
i think funny should not be focused on
what because yes
wait funny shouldn't be focused on what
do you mean i think funny is a byproduct
of what are your thoughts
i think funny is something that's raw
it's it's something that someone just
has because the people who are the
stupidest is some are the people that
are always telling who's funny and who's
not
wrong
i think the thing went off
it did oh yeah damn it
but i just don't uh respect like oh this
guy is funny he just has it it's like
the stupidest people that like they
don't have anything other than their
natural who do you have in mind right
now talent so they try to just
make make everyone feel like that's the
most important thing
well what's comedy supposed to be
it's networking man it's about business
now honestly the most une unfunny things
are the funniest
yeah but what do you mean but i want to
hear that so you don't think camera's
supposed to be funny no i think it's
supposed to be funny but i don't think
it should be like your natural funniness
should be the the most important thing i
think working at it is
more impressive well i think it's both i
have this it would be both for sure
right but you can't change how much fun
you were born with and to focus on that
is
either way if you have it then it's
i mean if you're funny you still have to
work on
creating that structure of being a
comedian though yeah so that's the focus
should be on is creating something with
what you have and not what you were born
with
more often times than not the people who
work harder get more
and that works in stand-up call like
work ethic is huge like you can see
people who can just like they're able to
be consistent maybe they're not killers
but they know
that they can show up and do their job
every single time get there 30 minutes
early
fill in the blank
and then those people get booked up just
for that
i mean i think you should be trying to
be funny or maybe it comes naturally to
you right or you want people to have a
good time so you want to entertain them
right yeah and there's nothing i mean
yeah well that's what we're doing we're
entertaining people some people i think
like some people are more caught up on
the pursuit do you think that
noisemakers
i thought i was trying to entertain
people it just sounds like you're not
participating in the conversation it
sounds like i'm bored
where are these rallies um riley isn't
so much into the pursuit of being funny
that he's like
guys uh comedy comedians on a podcast
that talk about comedy that's not chill
dude
yeah that's something that's happening
then he goes
let's make puns
dude horses no i mean i no sorry i
wasn't trying i really wasn't trying to
interrupt
i was honestly just trying to see what
[Music]
you're like a nice queef riley
you're an adequate
yeah the creeps are cool though
i like a queen everyone hates the big
vagina i like queef but what about
queef beef queef beef it's a new canned
meat griefsboro baptist
church did you just say queefsborough
baptist church that's the one that like
they raised their kids to be a big big
big lips
yeah
mamas they communicate through queefs
what did you say
they're like dolphins where like every
noise is like a little they can hear it
from afar
[Music]
wow my mom needs me
she's queefing for you is there a
whoopee cushion factory nearby it's a
queen no that's queef town
hey where are you guys from queef town i
mean well like the difference between
queefs and farts is like queefs are in
the vagina they're like air trapped in
the vagina right we've started what
happened probably talks dude
when riley talks
queefing dude back to like where it's 16
and yeah
yo guys no
dudes no dude queefs are like lit that's
what like i really based my comedy off
of queefs
but [ __ ] aryans per minute i'm just
saying queefs are better than farts you
know
okay i think
i don't know have you ever do farts not
true queef pretty chill yeah
actually they wouldn't be tight-knit
technically a loosening yeah loose yeah
it's a loose air oh yeah yeah
yeah
loose dude
you know how some like african tribes
put like the little
circle on their lips to extend their
lips
they're like gages
yes
and
well i feel like i don't know tricks
could should have like gages and their
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] does that mean
wait what no let him explain that
because that makes no sense where are
they going to put them right
where are they going to put them and why
would you want them to have looser lips
not i mean you know they're chilling
loose lips
it's like putting large things in your a
a curd i mean uh a bean curtain
like what you know like like a bead
bead oh yeah riley i said beans
have you ever seen a vagina
um
yeah
he has dude but i've also seen an
earlobe and like these are these aren't
that big of it you're telling me you're
saying that these aren't that big but
like they can get really big
i don't know i'm saying it's just like
there's so much to try are you just
playing
a little bit yeah i mean they're pretty
they're like
i thought the avatar thing the thing in
avatar was kind of hot where they're
they're
the blue dicks no like their hair is
just like yeah like their chicks their
hair's their dick
they can connect with their horses
through their
dick
they can connect to their horse with
their hair decks
yeah and that's what they use they
literally they [ __ ] horses in that movie
i i think everyone forgets that they
[ __ ] horses
not a lot of people know this and
dragons but they [ __ ] horses and dragons
in that movie not a lot of people know
that i often ride by forget it oh sorry
that's true they forget it i often ride
my horse by sticking my [ __ ] into it
you gotta oil it that way that's how you
get it started
it's like a key
yeah it's like uh
sorry guys i'm having trouble starting
it's like one of those things
you go to the mechanic and they put that
thing in to figure out what's wrong with
your car because you go to the mechanic
the guy just like [ __ ] your horse he's
like yep
uh
broken
spine
they made the little computer they put
underneath here yeah yeah so like the
mechanic is that yeah i can hear you
do you wanna
check yeah that's better hello hello
make some
comment if oh it's not even streaming
hey riley
you think tonight's gonna be your night
finding a woman this thing is just like
sugar water
it's actually no sugar no there's so
much it's filtered water it's better
oh is it cane sugar sugar
just because it's better than a gatorade
it doesn't mean
like drinking it
yeah the thing is it has all these like
vitamins it has all these vitamins i
want the vitamins i don't want the sugar
but it's gluten free i guess the sugar
like preserves it probably
i think it makes it sweeter
no it makes it sweeter but also
preserves it that's salt
uh no sugar can do that too like a
really
like a sugary thing can like make it
last longer like honey lasts forever
because [ __ ] sugar sugar
sugar maple spices let's say sugar what
else is going on say sugar one more time
[ __ ]
sugar honey iced tea sugar honey can i
go pee
no uh no you're not allowed to leave if
you get if it's a pp on the podcast
anyway
this drink is called blackout berry
dude it's the name of my buddy in uh
college called a blackout berry
i don't believe you for a second
because you would always um
go to blackout sales
is that a thing
you know for someone who who did it was
like i don't know anything about improv
you you were to associate a lot in your
comedy
yeah i mean i love improv don't get me
wrong yeah you were a theater kid
yeah i was an improv kid
um
no i did one i did there was like one
night of theater where we did improv
it was like a really fun night because
everyone's just like
improv
whoa
yeah that's the energy of improv
let's watch some improv guys just say
yes to everything yeah come on
guys
the best time
those are the wildest nights
guys tonight we're not going to say no
to anything
it's not
just go out after the improv group do
some crack with her buddies
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] everything up
how'd you do that i was gonna read the
chat and
then it didn't end up happening is it
still recording though
yeah
so we're still hot and spicy
yeah i just wanted to see what people
were saying it's like if i don't see the
live chat when it happens i don't know
how to see it again i don't think i can
see it again it disappears the live chat
is the best because when people comment
they're like thinking about it but in
the live chat they're just saying
whatever comes to the top of their mind
like variable yeah they're not on there
right now
no yeah
i uh accidentally raced both places
where they i had it
but yeah i mean maybe this time we can
save it somehow
we lost the livestream damn your fans
are done you want to ask them some
questions like this like they keep
looking for it after like they keep
going down i'm sure like rehash they
have to like redirect you know
i know causing them some real labor on
their end we should ask some man i get
wi-fi it is it's my uh i think what's
happening is it's like you read that
yeah sounds fine huh
everyone turn the wi-fi off on your
phone maybe that'll help all right
or you guys have some questions i guess
yeah yeah
we asked you questions i'll pull it up
so what um what do you guys
what do you guys can you say something
funny or
you guys do
yeah what's
what's who said that who said say
something funny
i did poor in miami
tour in miami yeah get us down there
dude is that a stripper you tore a hole
in
i tore a hole in it just like there's a
hole in your dad's towels
whoa reference from yesterday's podcast
go check that one out
as long as riley doesn't want to delete
it it'll be up
letters from jewish people saying that
he's a terrible person he'll want that
podcast we should just i just like
deleting everything i i ever did on the
internet because i don't like to save
her to save our ears someone said how
about an intro
an intro intro that's what their
question was what is it like an hour in
like say uh
welcome to hans's podcast
hans kim
[ __ ] hey that's hans that's the guy
whose podcast this is and justin
essenmacher hey
sorry i'm justin
just in time to ruin the podcast
um that hurt
phillip garcia
i'm sure to fill up your ears let's all
say one fun fact about ourselves okay oh
i want to hear i'll go first all right
one time when i was a kid i like threw
up a hammer
into the sky and it landed on my head
that makes so much sense why didn't you
say this earlier and i would have
understood and i did that like three
times in a row like i kept trying to
catch you forgot you threw it because
you got hit
i knew i threw it but i was like i can
catch it because i wanted to catch it
but i don't know why i never caught it i
never like it never like you thought you
could catch and it landed i distinctly
remember this like it landed on my head
like hammer
the hammer part first or like the nail
or you nailed to something and it and
landed in my head yeah three times so
then you're like
i'm gonna get it the second time i read
it the second time and then you walk in
the house and you're like i don't know
my name mom what's wrong she's like well
you hit your head no they didn't know i
never told anyone about it did you know
the hammer is like for the wall
you wanna
tell cat right there
dude your [ __ ] house is bringing bill
you can't you can fill up you cannot sit
there you're the most distracted person
ever i know i'm sorry
no i mean i feel like it's pretty even
you're gonna see kyle rittenhouse in
that cat soon
what do you mean remember last time you
were staring off into the distance think
about kyle redhouse's life in 40 years i
was like that poor dude
that poor dude i feel like he's very uh
he got
he got uh he got crucified in the court
of public opinion yeah
that poor dude he got off scot-free
who do you think is the most who's gonna
hire him who is the funniest person
i think he should go into show business
he's going to be touring you know we're
going to be begging a feature for him
he's going to have security guards with
air 15. i can't believe that guy's doing
stand-up comedy right now so that that
degrades our art form
oh wait like he always kills
his uh like album title is going to be
like one crazy night in where what was
it
kansas yeah or kansas okay um one f-dub
night
was it's gonna be called and
it's going to be called killing
yeah killing the crowd
mowing blowing them down
fighting riots self-defense with kyle
him and o.j should make a him and oj
should make a show called self-defense
that'd be really self-offensive it went
down again
dude why does it keep going down because
your wi-fi is not that good
what if we put it on our phone we're
also outside
put it on the phone spot that's crazy
that's even worse
a phone hot spot yeah
whatever we'll just put the whole thing
up
that works too
brain dead podcast lol hammer happen
yay
is this hanza's van fortier one coach
ooh the sopranos reference
how about an intro who references
sopranos
nobody i think he just really someone
really likes the sopranos which makes
sense he's just like hey like anything
you say is just like oh is that from
tony tony did say the intro one time
why do people just say
why do people knew intro because they're
weak and they need to be true want to
know who they're interested they want to
know what they're listening to dude give
me your best intro though right now hey
welcome to the podcast where we talk
about anything even crap
this podcast we got special guests
justin essenmaker
he looks like white trash and
he's from detroit so that makes sense
he's a blue collar uaw
[ __ ]
saltable earth americana [ __ ] white
said eyes
then we have philip that was just justin
this is his best intro
yeah dude hans do phillip now
he's a jovial guy and a nice guy he's
very soft he won't hurt you unless you
don't unless you ask him to clean up his
mess in the kitchen he hates cleaning up
after himself yeah
is this riley
well you didn't do you
yeah it is your host
hans kim asian man what's the name of
your podcast
baby back ribs
i like that that's the name i would
rather name it like queef zone or
something no call it yeah
call it baby welcome to the zones
there's come town
zone queef
you could totally be queef zone i feel
like you'd just naturally siphon off
their fan base uh which should probably
fit right in hey you guys been listening
to what podcasts
is queef
fans of queef and when you go to your
shows
they all
they all queef for you when you get on
stage
and then everybody's queefing that would
be awesome it smells like a real quiche
like a big breeze of wind comes by your
face
this time
it's queef season it's queef season we
don't have eddie here to balance out
with our his masculinity
yeah
he's he's out somewhere huffing queefs
huffing as lady's queef
he's always going out for this lady not
giving me a ride to hearst
yeah hey riley you had a hurt you had
some luck with the bar last night with
women
yeah
and a really old guy too right no but
there was well there was a guy that was
like literally cosby like he was like on
black
but like yeah i mean yeah he's black but
like that's not why like he was like he
looked kind of like cosby but he was
just he was just on the door he was just
on the dance floor like uh roofing
people he was just like throwing them up
chilling like i don't know
like you always come up to me and like
fist bump me be like yeah all right oh
my god yeah hitman riley the most
awkward people i've ever seen on the
dance floor in my life we have it on
video you're dancing what are you
talking about bro i was going to bro
this kid stood more that's the stillest
i've ever seen riley stand was on the
dance floor i'm like you're supposed to
move and he's just like sitting there
and he's watching people and we're like
what are you doing what do you want me
to do that looks like a [ __ ] ghost
that's not true at all i mean i think
it's a little low blow to criticize
people's behavior in a bar because i
mean who knows how to act normally in a
bar it's a weird situation well it's not
that weird there's just people you
interact with people but like i mean
what's i mean i don't know i can't
really dance like i mean no we saw that
there's no problem
and if you can't dance like i mean
there's no problem with just like you're
no friend i would mind standing there
swaying like dude he was swaying with
that girl dude he did that high school
dance where they grind and this was
riley dancing with a girl
i don't okay what am i supposed to do he
was there and she's like going hard and
he's like yeah you know like riley's
about to get his ass beat and this girl
comes back and she had the biggest man
in the bar with him
i'm like riley's about to die and we
can't protect him he was like we looked
and we go yeah riley's on his own riley
you're on here what the
the only girl the youngest girl you
dance with just leave me next no we
watched you but we're like he's gonna
have to learn him on himself to by
himself today it was so easy what the
[ __ ] to watch riley just it was the best
dude it was the greatest i mean i don't
think i struck out he's being social
he's talking to people he doesn't have
fear like we do because we're old i
don't have fear i'm just smart is that
why you were cowering in the corner
man
oh i was just chilling man my stomach
felt so bad last night
i was so [ __ ] up
uh yeah probably
this stuff i was oh that's too bad and
then also like
hungover
that fried cheese sucks so bad they
didn't they didn't really fry yeah we
just ate it because it was cheese i love
cheese
i'm sorry that
i gave you some stuff and then it just
made your night worse it was supposed to
do the opposite i know i kind of i was
sad about it because i'm like i'm not
even enjoying myself
i was just like in pain but i don't
think i think it was just my hangover
stomach and then
and then we put then i put that in there
and it was just like
bad idea i was just hot and sweaty and
like
the my eyes were kind of blurry that's
it then i'm like [ __ ]
and then we were in that room that small
comedy room and there wasn't enough
people in there yeah and the energy was
really weird yeah like this is not a
good vibe and it was freezing i couldn't
get warm at all yesterday it was a
terrible night it was yeah it was
i honestly we got there and i'm like man
we got to drive all the way back and we
came all the way out here for there's no
offense i'm like this is
dude that crowd was so stupid i don't
know if they that's like how they had to
become to defend themselves from some of
the shitty
uh
bombs that happened that night
but
they were like
they were unwield they were like just
talking they wanted to participate they
just didn't know there was a show we
grown men that were acting like 12 year
olds yes
they're like how old are you they're
like 13 yeah
and then you ask another guy and like
eventually hans tells someone
hey this isn't like a thing like you
don't talk back and forth
and then after he gets told to shut up
he he proceeds to then build the longest
straw in the world coming out of one cup
and every time the waitress comes around
it's like can i get you anything else
and then you're gonna take that he's
like no don't don't take this
so he's like proud of it and he's like
now that he doesn't have a way to
express himself in the comments people
are breaking down mentally inside comedy
shows
it's like you don't have to be here
they're like yeah but no i i came so i'm
gonna watch the whole [ __ ] thing
people were killing people were doing
good but then someone else would go up
they were having fun man
riley did well yeah i had fun yeah
figures they were laughing at you after
you left though
that's good what do you mean like
they're like they laughed and then like
the house went up afterwards and they're
like yeah what'd y'all think of that guy
and they're like
well that was right
that was actually our make-a-wish uh
part of the show
yeah i hated that crowd
um that was a good one i loved the crowd
i know
how do you think it feels to be someone
who's not a comic you like you must drop
the strength like babe honey like
you know what you've been saying we're
not doing too well and we want to get
out more we're going to do different
things we're going to go this place down
the street found out there's a comedy
club in town right let's go hit it up
and you go
and then you get there
it's like 10 comics
that
and you get there but it's like when you
go to a comedy show you're it's like
going to a bar
you don't want to go out to a bar that
has nobody in it yeah it's kind of you
might you do a comedy show you're like
one of eight people
it's depressing but you're also like
yeah she said it's usually more full
weird it is more full usually and i was
like that's the first time i've ever
been but everyone always says it's like
that's one of the best rooms
yeah but that's what it is on an off
night i feel bad when you go and you
like bark people into a comedy show and
they're like the first two and you're
like
i'm so sorry that we did this to you in
a minute but then because then those
people feel obligated they're like [ __ ]
we're here and now we feel bad so we
stay and it's like yeah you can leave
but people are just like no i'm going to
stay but they hate it i've done multiple
shows at native hostel in austin where
there's like
big rooms and there's four people in
there yeah the comics are laughing at
you
more than people are laughing at you
because they're like
listening to you they know where your
jokes usually land
they're just like hearing them go softly
into the dark knight it's like it's hot
up there with only four people in it no
one can yeah
i mean i wouldn't mind performing for
six people if they were like trying to
you know like right it's like watching a
netflix show where if you're not
enjoying it the show gets worse
so if you're not enjoying it then the
comedian can see you not enjoying it and
then they just start doing worse and
worse and getting sad
right well sometimes i feel like the
smaller rooms are like the best rooms
sometimes because like there's there's
all that hard in there
yeah like i thought that was like that
too that's how i came up so i'm still
getting used to i would like to i want
to start performing in front of crowds
because i'm usually just in front of
like nobody so i'm fine with it yeah but
like and that's what i do i'm cool with
it but
sorry no i like small crowds but i was
like i'd like bigger crowds because i
also need to work that muscle but it's
just getting on more shows you know
yeah so you like telling stories at a
party
i mean sure because that's pretty much
like well is that what that's what it
was stand-up comedy
what'd you say that's what people say
what is like the difference between a
small and a big crowd
i don't know there are different things
like this it's a small crowd it depends
on what it's composed of i guess like
there's
couples like last night that was like
four sets of couples and then whoever
hans got ditched by
um actually dracula had to leave
she had to go back to her coffin yeah
um
yeah it was like all couples so they're
all like trying to impress their date
they're trying to laugh at the correct
hey babe watch this i'm gonna [ __ ] up
the queen check out my laugh it's sexy
as [ __ ] it was like they were in the
back of a taxi they were telling us
everything burying their souls like the
one couple in the front like one guy was
like are y'all are y'all dating and then
the guy is like
yeah and then the girl's like no we're
in an open relationship and the guy's
just like yeah
and you're just like
wow
cuck and then you keep going and it's
like the next people are idiots they're
the 25 year old that's like i'm 13.
the one with the long straw yeah and
then the other couple that's not the
best
couple that's like honestly laughing at
everything
there was uh
there was a girl in the front row and
this comic said a joke about cheap
pregnancy tests to feel more alive yeah
and then this girl's like dollar tree
there's no way that that's quality
that's not your best contribution you
just like it because you're the one that
said it
like why no that i think she's just
saying that's where like she gets her
test she's verbally funny
to name a shitty store
like
dollar trees are just so funny you can
get them there though exactly like
that's just humor to her is just
the minutia of her day-to-day life thank
you for the tag
like how does that help them i have a
joke that's only how i talk about dollar
tree pregnancy chest i have a whole bit
about it
so she said it and i was like that lady
needs to see me
but also like if you turn on the
audience like it just kind of ruins the
vibe like that one guy yeah you don't
want to be like an [ __ ] because
people are like having fun and then
you're just like no you can't talk
anymore and they're just like and then
they're just not having fun anymore yeah
like bill hicks you got a toy with them
though
it's toying with them and using what
they say today because if you don't say
anything then they're not going to
respect you
that's not true yes if you just let them
run ranch oh yeah i mean yeah [ __ ] yeah
i guess yeah you're right you got to
have some boundaries be like you can't
just ruin my bits
let me spank you but then let me also
make a fake somehow publicly humiliate
you
yeah i mean that's why they do it they
they want to be roasted they like roast
me
yeah true they do like it
they love it
like oh you got me so hard dude
that roast was so sick man dude you the
way you humiliated me turned me on so
much dude my girl's not gonna [ __ ] me
now it's awesome i love it
do it again man i got a jerk tonight
and what happened tonight
but i'd say the difference between big
crowds and small crowds is like a big
crowd they're just one giant mass
yeah
you can wield them around but if it's
small enough then they're individuals
and you have to like talk to them
individually
yeah
that's a good point
he wants to cross but he can't
oh [ __ ] i just stuck my pinky in his
nose
but um i mean
after that
i went with that
hagrid old lady to
that arcade and then
went to her house
did she have to go home to watch her
grandkids or what
she had to turn off the tea kettle
she are you kidding me she had a she had
to turn off her uh witch's bro dude
that's dangerous
she had to um change her colostomy bag
and queef
queef lost to me back
so i gotta go
queef in the bathroom sorry there's a
curfew at the nursing home she like know
you from
[Music]
kill tonight then she that came out to
your show
uh
she saw me at the secret show
she also saw lucas mccrary and casey
rocket and someone gave her a jacket
apparently
i've seen her jacket i've seen her bro
yeah riley saw her i've seen her like uh
she's in austin all the time hopefully
i'll see her and call her a [ __ ] does
she live here
she lives in yeah she lives here but she
goes to austin a lot for work she works
at like some school
helping disabled kids have enough
wheelchairs or something
maybe that's why she hates me she's a
reminder of one of her students yeah
she's like i came here to escape work
not to do more charity
uh why is there a wheelchair in here in
this garage though because we've had it
forever
why'd you have a forever no one's ever
needed it we just have i need it i would
love it i would love a wheelchair it's
broken we've thought about donating it
but
donating in a broken wheelchair yeah
we'll spoken about kind of donate it
riley
donate it but
there's no wheels on it who would want
it there is wheels on it actually there
is no wheel there's no rubber you should
take it down to austin and put it on the
side of the road to a homeless person
give it to a homeless person i can do
wheelies i wouldn't call that broken
though i would just call that missing a
part i would call it right it's a rally
wheelchair yeah it's kind of yeah it is
[Music]
it's like one of my few childhood
memories well is that really true
yes it is how did that happen and what
are you doing honestly i have no idea i
know it was a bob the builder hammer and
i was throwing it up i threw it three
times and it hit my face it's not
a hammer no no no it is it is it's a
kid's hammer but it was still made of
metal no it wasn't it wasn't like a lego
is that why you got that it wasn't like
an industrial hammer but it was like
it was like uh like a like a little you
know like bit a little bit bigger than
like a wine hammer you know what's a
wine hammer you've never seen a wine
hammer uh this is some white people [ __ ]
it's the one where you use it to make it
it has it has it's actually more
dangerous than a regular it has a spike
on the back
you use it to like [ __ ] like dig into
the cork and then
and then like put the cork back in you
can hammer it back okay that's a wine
i have never seen it i thought you were
just making stuff up again
my brothers were playing with the hose
on the trampoline
like the water hose
and i yanked on it when i was off the
trampoline and it came like whipping
back in it
right in the tooth
what was it a snake a water hose oh
uh
yikes dude one time i [ __ ] one time i
had a metal baseball bat and i i was
really angry and i like hit the
basket there was a basketball on the
ground and i hit the basketball and it
bounced back up and hit me in the face i
did that before too my friend we were
playing the ball
he pitched it to me and i hit myself in
the face
and then once
oh sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry one time
one time we were up north when we were
younger and my cousin was swinging a bat
and he didn't know i was behind him
and uh he hit me right in the [ __ ]
head with a bat
you all make a lot more sense to me
though
just
your history
you're not prone to injuries
i just i'm not not like massive back to
head injuries or no that wasn't massive
it wasn't massive just enough just
enough compounded i once threw a
baseball and i didn't see the tree right
in front of me and the baseball hit the
tree and hit me in the face
you didn't see the tree right in front
of me yeah
how
i was trying to throw around the tree i
guess one time we got into a rock fight
and i threw one really far and it hit a
kid right in the forehead definitely had
a couple bad rock fights as a kid yeah
mud fights mud fights my mom got some
america
i did do the whole hit of baseball like
play uh play baseball with the
basketball and then you hit it with the
bat and then it comes back around and it
and you're like oh yeah i guess i did
have a couple hits you ever hit yourself
with like a razor scooter on the ankle
yeah
death
yeah the worst it's really bad i mean
the you're watching it's like remember
like the funny bone
like when you hit your funny bone still
have it yeah it's like isn't it kind of
[ __ ] that people that like your
parents are just like oh that's just
your funny bone oh oh word that means
i'm like not in pain anymore word
no it's funny like it just seems like it
doesn't solve anything like calling it a
funny bone it's okay
that's just like funny leukemia
yeah that's your funny cancer this is
your fault
you're funny chemo you're funny bald now
i have funny aids
time for your funny amputation that's
still not cool funny circumcision
yeah here comes time for your funny
haircut riley
hey dude honey i'm only funny cheating
on you that's okay yeah
it's a bit yeah it's a bit
i'm only only sleeping with your sister
because it's a bit
yeah dude you don't get the bit honey
you're not a comedian you're not you
don't understand funny this is she gets
it
yeah she lets it happen all the time and
we laugh the whole time
at home
watching all the kids we're having funny
sex it's just funny it's just funny it's
hilarious when i
[ __ ] her
yeah when i'm [ __ ] hurt i'm not even
thinking of you that's how funny it is
last night i just like got a funny dui
and funny funny cop
funny went to jail yeah got a funny
attorney you know it should have been a
funny protest
and used my funny ar-15
to put some funny holes in people
funny that's funny
that's funny comedy makes everything
better yeah
it's the sauce of life name one thing it
doesn't make better even funerals
even funerals i'm making jokes people oh
look you see that person in the casket
we all loved them but you know let me
tell you what he's a piece of [ __ ]
dude that's actually what my uncle did
like at my grandma's funeral like he was
just like making jokes about like
she was like yeah we're all like really
annoyed by her and she was like [ __ ]
annoying and [ __ ] like you were just
laughing he said that like he said that
like five times during his speech we're
all just like what wait
yeah no i really [ __ ] hated her dude
i mean you guys know what i mean she was
terrible her cooking sucked he kept
sneaking in noids
yeah i don't know yeah he's just like
saying he's like yeah you know she was
like annoying
yeah i'll read the
uh
but i feel like i would write i would
have a good funeral speech like i
honestly can't wait until someone dies
so i can just like do a speech at a
funeral that's the stuff what the [ __ ]
was so selfish
yeah no dude i really can't wait for him
to die because i've been writing a
speech for years about dude your speech
is so good man yeah hey great job at the
funeral
but you never will
i'll send it to you
i'll send it to you before you die so
you know how good it is and then hurry
up and die so i can say it i'll put in
the cloud yeah
i mean other people's funerals aren't a
chance for you to kill it's not stage
time
um more about that in your mind no you
know
some of us don't open for rogue and some
of us can only do funerals okay
i can only get funeral work
i get about 10 minutes in at weddings
that i officiate dude what if you hired
like a [ __ ] open micro to dude yeah
dude i got this kid's birthday party
next week dude and it's i'm gonna crush
i got this kid's birthday party and i'm
just so excited i can't wait till some
of y'all die so i can like
have some roast i'm trying to get out
you know what i mean why don't you say
one now
like not for y'all i haven't really been
friends with y'all long enough to be
like yeah i'm going to the funeral
but
that's why you're not invited if it
makes you feel better you wouldn't come
to my funeral weekend i'll feel like
we're forever indebted
but you wouldn't have came to me my
funeral is going to be kind of like a
you know a lit part of you got to be
kind of exclusive
yeah like i don't know like we can't
just let everybody in because like
that wouldn't be true it wouldn't be lit
who do you think is going to what if
you're like planning a crash into your
funeral yo dude hey what's the dress
attire first funeral dude uh make sure
you bring your flannels hoodies and
[ __ ] nikes dude
everyone is just a bunch of people like
vaping at the same time everyone
i'll pull the vape smoke into your
coffin everyone gets hit in the head
before you come into this funeral with a
hammer
everyone has to listen to
chance the rapper
it's just astroworld the entire time
yeah actually my funeral is gonna be at
astroworld next year
don't say that
no not next year i mean the year after
don't say that
do you think astroworld just cancels
forever are they going to be back next
year i think anyway guys
we all know you know what happened last
year
it's not like that so do you think
travis scott's gonna make a a farewell
song to the people that died at his
concerts like
so long my friends
probably not it's gonna make it's gonna
make concerts in general probably more
expensive
yeah they gotta up the [ __ ] yeah yeah
true man dude the ambulance dude
everything about it travis policies
astroworld was was the music industries
911.
seriously everything's going to change
like tsa is going to be out there like
like you're gonna have to have like
you're gonna be like hey i'm in you know
i hope let me get the window seat like
that yeah it's gonna be a whole big
thing now
i don't know if it's gonna be that big
yeah
there's really nos
you think that you have a problem
astroworld was no it's not i don't know
but like definitely i mean they're gonna
that they could keep that in mind it's
better than castro world it's just
breadlines and soup kitchens fidel
castro 1950s classic vehicles
um
how about castrated world
it's their funeral
everyone has to cut their balls off at
my funeral
we all turned pale dude thank god i
wasn't going to show up to your funeral
you know
well
get it
because you don't have any balls
no he doesn't want to be castrated yeah
i don't want to be castrated dude why
not bro
because i like my balls
on your face i could go i think i was
talking i think i would be better
without my balls
yes
like once i'm done with them i might get
rid of them like if they're not
producing whatever
you're just gonna have a dick
yeah do you do balls you can't come
anymore handsome like right now my balls
are under your comfy
i always adjust them bro i think i'm
gonna get
them out my
think i'm gonna get up squeezing your
balls no i had to like pull them out
yeah i know it's uncomfortable that's
why i wear sweats
i'm gonna get a ball reduction surgery
maybe you should just try coming
but all the women keep leaving no you're
not gonna have a group drink are you
being serious because i also i have
really big balls
are you do you also have big balls
what are you talking about
what like like do like do like a like
if i curl up my my middle finger they're
like
a little like probably about
maybe you should stop eating so much uh
gluten
your balls get bigger from eating gluten
yeah what i don't think my balls are
well
definitely well she has a hammer he has
the hammer brain so he thinks
differently your balls are bigger if
there are women in around you that are
more promiscuous
they're [ __ ] a lot of different dudes
you need to produce more semen to pump
into their vaginas so you get bigger
balls i don't think that's true that's
definitely true chimpanzees have
uh
gorillas are very small balls is the
semen like in the ball outside of the
testicle
even travels outside the balls is it in
the testicle or is it like kind of
what's inside the scrotum yeah that's
why women don't produce there's a
testicle those little balls
you guys have those
we have testicles that's why women don't
produce any semen if there was if semen
was produced outside the testicles then
women would make semen too
no no it's produced in the testicle but
do they kind of like give it out like
it's like free free range like
in like the scrotum hey do you have free
range come here or not because i don't
like organically i got pasta raised [ __ ]
i don't think there's any like storage
where does it get stored
in your balls or
in her mouth it's uh and your
girlfriend's mouth it's funny you can
say free range for like anything to be
like yeah they have free range to deal
yeah like right to navigate about the
cage yeah like right like
riley's like a free range thought they
had like free reigns he's a free-range
thinker dude
i'm like really gets his thoughts from
anywhere i get my thoughts from a local
farmer's market
thoughts market thoughts here by your
thoughts he's got freedom oh i'll take
ten stupid thoughts and one smart
thought
and one juicy because you know i got a
sweet tooth
and i'll take one you go kid let me just
hit you on the head with a hammer can i
get
one really scary thought i'll take two
love thoughts and three instagram
thoughts and i'll take five on it
and three
funny thoughts
[Laughter]
and another one is gonna be a
how is your uh describe your thoughts
horny thoughts
uh are your horny thoughts any good
today
yeah they're pretty cool
it's mostly corny thoughts
horny thoughts about corn
corn
corn sucks i love hardcore i hate corn i
like corn
why do you hate corn it's the worst
thing in the world dude it's just like
not good man i like
it you look like you don't eat any
vegetables though i eat so many
vegetables bro i love you you look like
you only eat sugar you don't eat a lot
of sugar but like i eat vegetables bro i
love veggies
i like pickled onions like pickles i
like
pickles okay i like pickled pickled feet
i like pickled i like all pickled eggs
and i have some okra that i never
[ __ ] made and i'm mad about it
you're real sad are you okay slimy now
probably okay
i like okra fried okra okra choke on the
uh [ __ ]
hey riley did you graduate high school
nah
college
did you go to school
okay
so uh i went i was homeschooled for one
year in uh kindergarten and you failed
too didn't you no but i feel like my mom
put me in special ed
wait you feel like it or were you in
special you would know if you're in
special ed they would be like hey well
let's go get riley off the short bus and
then and then you go to class and you
figure well it's home schooled
so you might have a short place at home
someone would be like all right
nap time
did you fail nap time
yeah i feel nap time i was too busy
awake
i think i'm getting dumber
yeah yeah you are we've noticed that as
well
just in this podcast
like that and then like just
since i've been out of college i've just
gotten tougher maybe you're [ __ ]
i'm feeling close like i feel like you
and i could really collapse i feel like
oh whoa why are you dragging me i feel
like i really need to eat food
like if we painted it right now
yeah i feel like i'm really hungry
well i think that after college you
start living a real life and then you
get a different kind of intelligence
and then people think that bookish
intelligence is more valuable but i
don't think it is i think school is like
[ __ ]
dude i mean yeah
it's cool
school is cool i'm cool for school
so you think that uh it was i had fun
like our education system is
no i hate it but i had fun like writing
papers
and i was like damn i just wrote like a
really concise paper yeah oh my god by
the end of my life it kind of forces you
to do that i was like at a point where i
was like i'm really good at school like
i figured this out i mean i was never
good at it good student
yeah easy you just show up every day
i hated school maybe that's where i went
wrong i would never show up i figured
that out my senior year after skipping
classes and [ __ ] i was like yeah you
just show up every day and you won't
fail like literally just show up you
can't fail if you show up yes you can
listen to the podcast maybe i'm a better
student because i was like i learned how
to sit and listen to information for
longer than like 15-30 minutes yeah you
found out what interesting information
sounds like right and this is what i'm
supposed to be doing
is listening and you're like oh i can
try to do that thing that i do for
things i actually care about for this
thing that no person could possibly care
about exactly yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
that we learned there i'm gonna say what
the [ __ ] are you telling us
yeah like like english
you know would have been nice
you know they would have taught us like
how to uh live after school that would
have been cool
yeah hey guys you probably should've
said one hey guys we're gonna teach you
how to investigate
dude hey we shouldn't teach you how to
invest in stocks and do stuff with your
money but they're like nope you really
got to learn this [ __ ] uh geometry
[ __ ]
why the [ __ ] do i need this well you see
you got to know how to make shapes
and do enough with shapes i think that
we have like a job market that isn't
really useful jobs no yes there's my job
market should change the job market yeah
there's no point like half the [ __ ] that
we learn give us something useful if you
want us to do these shitty ass jobs
my school taught me how to please the
man yeah you're like you gotta go out
there and please the man
do what he says
yeah so then you get out of school and
then you then you're like oh i got to
follow this structure i need this nine
to five so i can keep my life going
and then
and then you're 55 and you're like what
the [ __ ] i didn't even follow a dream i
just got this accounting job and i feel
i got security
it's perfectly setting you up for an
accounting yeah he's like forget about
the math why do i hate myself
yeah teach me the math and why i'm about
to kill myself yeah can you please teach
me how to
have jobs that are useful we have jobs
that waste your time or like make
[ __ ] menial tasks slightly cheaper
than robots so that yeah anything that
you can learn that's useful is not going
to be
applicable to a real world job because
they're not trying to make you a smart
person yeah you're just trying to waste
your time you just need to make this
product you just need to do
do it now yeah for at least eight hours
a day why do we have to do it eight
hours well that's because we
it hasn't all around here buddy it has
to be eight hours because then if it's
not eight hours then we don't get all
the [ __ ] done well i got my [ __ ] done in
an hour can i go home and get paid for
eight hours no you gotta stay here all
day why it's not like that anymore
why not because now we work from home
and then now the metaverse is gonna
happen and now we don't have jobs and
now we don't need jobs and they're just
gonna give us money eventually
facebook's going to run the world and
we're all going to live in let's go into
the metaverse after this guys can we go
back please i hate the real world please
i can't wait to hang out with versus
really shitty characters
it's just going to be so easy dude my
metaverse wife is so hot
i think that
is what happens to food
the jobs that we could have could be
much more fulfilling but they're not
yeah
we're just gonna get set up on ivs and
then sit in the metaverse and decide
it's gonna be nice how do you get your
nutrients i get it from a bag and then i
just sit there and then i don't move
and then i'm really happy
i shower in the mouth
we're gonna live in a zoo
and robots are gonna do everything that
we need and then we're gonna get food
and they're gonna build us houses and
stuff and we're just gonna get to do
whatever we want make art
figure out culture
read 16th century
french poetry that is culture though
making buildings and stuff yeah and then
it's gonna be like a new renaissance
period just build buildings
survival you think so it's like a new
renaissance period where we're just like
navigating this new thing we've created
yeah for sure we're going to make much
better art we're going to look back at
this art and be like damn these these
are animals just struggling to survive
right well if we all get out plug
ourselves our consciousness into one
thing like one community that's society
it already is
yeah but it's not it's all separated no
it's not it's like we're all arguing
what do you get up every day and you you
you look at instagram stories to see
what you're gonna do in real life
[Music]
well i just mean like we're like we're
our we already know we're already like
connected
uh
conscious like on a spiritual level so
like we just need to tap into that and
then everybody will then everything will
be fine literally everything will be
fine after that there can't be fine
because everybody wants power people no
but if they take acid and then realize
that they don't need power those power
people aren't going to take acid no if
they if they take acid and realize that
they already have as much power as they
need
then they're going to get more they want
more power people with power want more
um yeah they won't as soon as they
realize they don't need it and they're
not just chasing after you know this
like false hope
of oh i'll have this someday that's not
the cure all the way but we have it what
we have to watch out is for the [ __ ]
lizards so what you're saying is we just
dump a whole bunch of acid into our
water supply and then everybody will be
honestly safe honestly yes
like i i don't know how it can make it
more clear than that the horses
we're gonna do it tonight my cords if
everyone takes acid like things will be
fine like everyone
will realize that it doesn't matter and
we're all just chilling what about
mushrooms why yeah no they can do that
too
today's choice mushroom but then it'll
just become politically divided today is
mushroom monday the world might be
happier if we just drug every day like
oh my gosh
tuesday
tuesday ecstasy third wednesday molly i
mean it'll make us
but then it won't actually do anything
we need more than just feelings we need
action i like feelings i know you do
feelings uh can really be strong
yeah
how do you feel
about women riley
they're lovely
nice are we staying here today
are we heading back tonight let's go
back
to austin on it yeah yeah
sounds good to me after the show
philip's just gonna come back here after
we're gone and
party with his family
no
go to olive garden no i have a show
tomorrow night
i gotta work otherwise i would
um
what do you think that would improve the
energy of this podcast right now
um
i don't know someone gave a topic is
there any comments well can we talk
about it offline
read the past comments hey do you think
the lions are gonna do
no in next year's slave trade
how do you think the lions are gonna the
next year's slave trade
did you see chiang chi
have you seen shanghai
what's saying shang chai what's that and
the five rings asian marvel is that a
tea
i love the shang chai
but you know the crazy thing is like
before this podcast happened we were
inside everybody was talking a lot
well there's always
stuff in front of us so it's like it
feels like i'm trapped inside of an
equipment you are trapped
you're trapped in your own head right
now
i'm just trying to take it
and you need to take a hammer and break
it open and get those thoughts out
mission in the corner
and then it came out what do you think
about kyle rittenhouse
we've talked about this too much
you can't talk about customers still
have no idea what you think isn't that
funny that not guilty not guilty it's
not guilty funny that like
like
we can only us a society can only talk
about one thing
no what do you mean we can talk about
the weather when they talk about like
the jobs the newest netflix show
people don't understand is that like
that's what they want
different things that's the liberal
mindset immediate media majority they
want it's just like whatever is popular
is like the one thing or just like
everybody yeah let's all hear on this
channel it's a conversation
yeah but it's like we should have a
national conversation about something
else you sound like you besides black
people conversation about what's
everyone doing later you see how what
are you doing later riley
uh
watching kyle rittenhouse videos
that's hot
you just said you didn't want to walk
kyle right in house i don't
and why did you bring it up
because i didn't bring it up yes brought
it up
he's yes ending my kyle rittenhouse bit
i'm yes and saying no
i know
let's talk about
riley you think you're gonna get a girl
tonight in dallas texas
you better not because then she's gonna
say maybe
you're gonna bring a girl back to my
mom's place dude
bring her back to austin just be like my
home's just three hours from here
are you like bit by something right now
yeah mosquitoes yeah why is that
happening like all of a sudden because
that they're here now skaters
i hate mosquitoes i love mosquitoes too
i think kyle rittenhouse
is
guilty of murdering two people
unnecessarily
totally didn't need to happen not guilty
i mean the protest had to happen because
people are mad about this dude dying but
then the counter protest to that protest
it's like you're
defending property it's like let them
destroy [ __ ] they deserve it
you think that people should be able to
just go destroy [ __ ] if there's
injustice yeah so we should just go burn
a town down if you don't like
reasoning for something there's no
injustice if he's not guilty
this is our world we shouldn't get it
nice
by burning cities down
cities that murder people
over long periods of time yeah burn them
down and then get rid of the cities
we have to
okay if we may if they make do you
rebuild the city or do you rebuild a
city or just let it crumble and just
make a better city
they want us to think
they want us to think there's that that
it's a it's an issue when it's really
not they're trying to control
the society that the races against each
other yes right to always keep us just
infuriating because
those people are defending the way
things are now which is bad for certain
races and they're like let's not talk
about race right even though things
aren't equal right now it's only about
race it's only ever been about race
right kind of almost
i mean white people are suffering too
under capitalism
i think everybody's suffering right now
and one percent yeah
except for the communism right yes
why it depends on what you mean by
communism i think that we need to have
community power
instead of being ruled over by people
who have money we should be having a
more democratic society
yeah but they're never going to let us
have that fully i think i like our
oligarchs so we should do what they say
no i don't want to do what they i don't
want to do what they have to say because
i don't like a lot of things that they
have to say who capitalists yeah yeah
but they have all the money and money is
power and speech so if they have all the
money then they get to tell us what to
do
and instead of having a small group of
people tell us what to do i think we
should all vote on it and then we'll
we'll have more freedom
because then we'll be ruled by ourselves
and we can vote on things instead of
just having people with money be like we
want a new stadium over here you think
we should have a we should have a more
hands-on
society basically yeah in terms of in
terms of like
voting like well it makes sense we all
have [ __ ] smartphones in our pocket
why don't we get sent out like polls
every week or so to like vote hey uh you
know
china's poking at us it again do y'all
wanna do i wanna do the sanction thing
again we can do that again and then it's
like yes or no and it like shows you a
three and a half minute video that like
blatantly explains what's going on yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah so we can as a society declare if
we want to drop bombs somewhere everyone
take acid
i mean it's better than having george
bush decides if he wants to drop a bomb
or not acid can also feed the ego though
too i mean acid is a acid is a hit or
miss depending on the person
yeah acid can make people really crazy
yeah it's not good for some people i
sometimes i don't
it gets intense like don't get like
ayahuasca then
yeah it's that's pretty that's
an experience though that's humbling
humbling anything i guess is what you're
saying is people need i don't know just
more drugs more drugs more drugs more
kindred more good drugs more
hallucinogenics
you are one of the people you
interviewed on 6th street now
i love [ __ ] hallucinogenics
when he talks a little bit it's just
like he stops maybe i ruined my mind
riley was staring in the bar the other
night with his mouth open last night he
was just like this
so what you're allowed to do that i look
where he was staring yeah you totally
are but i looked like what corner he was
staring i was like sure he's probably
like looking at like a neon sign or
something you know i turn around it's
just like nothing it's the most boring
corner of the barn i was looking at the
screen bro what do you think there was
no screen in that corner what was i
looking at like three beer posters
so why there's
boobies
it didn't matter what i was looking at i
was thinking about something i wasn't
like oh look at the three beer things
what were you thinking about i don't
know i forget we're playing facebook and
they were like i'm like oh you lost
possession he goes i don't need my
possessions man
it's true you know
expert at wordplay
he hears a word you say and then he
he has like 17 definitions of what i'm
going to say i'll choose this one yeah
you should learn more words
you know enough words i don't know that
many you know possession i know rhyming
double meaning
you know rhyming how do you rhyme
by doing it sublime
no no no no no no
sublime rhyme
that's a crime i'm on time yeah
i have a line
a live scooter
i mean do you think that
we
should have more than five percent of
the gdp as millennials
um yes isn't it kind of [ __ ] how all
our friends are like uber drivers and
[ __ ]
fast food employees
yeah the i think they're young well we
have college education so
we have good jobs dude we're the
smartest people yeah dude i'm a server
and then you're talking about your
friends being lyft drivers and fast food
workers some of the best jobs you can be
is that the case that's not a good job
is it the case there's a joke i'm
kidding are we just living in like
kidding is the world just changing too
serious dude smart uh young people are
the smartest people we know
yeah riley i'm really going to believe
you when you say it we know you young
kid generation 15 year old is way
smarter i think you know right now is
way smarter than like an 80 year old
right now like so like we should have
the money dude we're the most educated
we know where to go we know where to put
the money into 54 of the millennials
still live at home with this because
we're looking after ourselves like but
we're like dude like this is gonna be
our future like and like old people are
just like i need to keep it i need to
i this is
i want honestly i think you guys kind of
talk the same old people and young
people that's it all people are like no
it's just the way it is and the young
kids are like no dude it's like our
future and they're like no this is our
world and they're like no it's like us
we should okay okay maybe we maybe we do
contact the same but like we should have
it though they're about to die like why
should you have it because we know we
know harder we're faster i just want to
hear his explanation yeah yeah like yeah
literally we're younger like we we
and we're like we're more in the future
than they are we're the future and
they're the past this is the tale as old
as time they want to it's just a habit
they're just used to [ __ ] over people
and they're like
but none of the laws change for them
like you know how some of them just they
just keep walking build a school both
ways in the snow mentality that's all it
is yeah i mean they're creatures of the
great depression or whatever yeah did i
have one book when i was in the vietnam
war
very traumatized times they're like
monkeys they're like cavemen and they
want to keep us save everything in the
caveman mentality yeah my mom's like 50
now she had some pretty good years
though like the 80s and 90s like some
peace times kind of
yeah and then she's like what i mean
like she talked about y2k like it was a
big deal i'm like god what i wouldn't
give for like another 2012 scare
everyone that was like hey i thought the
calendar ends this year i wouldn't even
watch that movie because i was so scared
2000 oh no no the y2k [ __ ] happened i
remember that i was
like 10. that's what happens when we
don't have any logic or spiritual
through
that's what we didn't yeah
a purpose
we can just be hijacked by some ancient
mayan religion because we have no common
myth that unites us as people
so we don't have any folklore
yeah hijacked by is a good prairie put
it because we were
they made movies
um
yeah
we make shitty how did that even start
they like found the calendar and they
were like some kids on the internet
what
no we're like we we're not being
provided any answers so let me go search
mayan texts calendars always end like
there's not an everlasting calendar
yeah we should be afraid every december
31st yeah yeah
the world's eventually going to end the
calendar ends so we just never know but
that's too obvious there needs to be at
least one more layer of intricacy for
the idiots to be like oh no i'm really
smart we kind of do get scared every
december thing we all scream at midnight
that's
true happy new year like we weren't
going to get man that was really loud on
the headphones it was really loud on the
headphones yeah
i try to back up too
but uh yeah i mean i think we should be
unified by our common humanity
and our future on on this planet and
that could be a unifying force but we're
just so used to religion and
national nationalism that it's not
captivating for us it's not sexy we'd
rather like have an enemy we can kill
because that's what we're used to
yeah instead of like saving the penguins
that's not
strong enough we're like that's not good
enough i need more dopamine
get me a cause that i can kill muslims
with
if killing muslims saved penguins we
would have saved penguins
by tenfold
that's true
are you
the penguin uh population is flourishing
and then it works the back it works the
other way too if you kill a penguin a
muslim is born so
that means that the taliban is actually
probably an inside job by big penguin
no it's by like yeah
so they like they like global warming
who penguins muslims
why because they're getting hotter
yeah because the woods are dying yeah
but whatever i'm getting even alive yeah
i am i can see that and i'm starting to
get bit up too are you gonna eat close
the garage door
i guess
yeah or do you want to end the podcast
yeah
in the podcast or close the garage door
i'd rather end it
i'm kind of having fun
oh okay i'm kind of down for
whatever i'm just i'm hungry
philip and i have a podcast and you two
can go be sad somewhere that's fine why
am i being sad
you're not being sad you're being angry
what am i being angry about
um
you're being angry no you're not being
angry you're
i love you
this is cool it looks pretty cool
whoa it looks like the sopranos yeah
dude it looks like a crazy meeting
a meeting of the minds
all these uploads
[Music]
what does that mean unappealing like who
said that they hate some flags
they hate the podcast so much that
that's not a new thing either
they don't hate it
they all they all hate it huh
i have to edit it then some of them like
it it's not live i'm just recording it
now i took his advice just weed
i'm gonna do my podcast inside of your
podcast
yeah let's do it all right let's do
phillips i guess
you just do recording but i'm gonna
press record on this one okay
i don't know how i'm gonna get the video
you can download it off youtube that's
what i'll do
that's how i send all my videos the
podcast to mine there
okay well we better
it's the exact same are you driving it
huh are you going to drive it
yeah i don't care drive us into the wall
i hope so i don't want to be driven no
my podcast is [ __ ] nuts
where's that milk box
i don't know man
i don't know man
i really don't know
i mean i think that
we can make a better world and we aren't
being given the tools that we need i
don't think we're able they don't let us
make decisions yeah even if they feel
like we're getting decisions able to
make they're not letting you make
decisions just like when you're going to
vote you get two options you get red or
blue that's it
that's it
hey everybody and welcome
i'm gonna use the
get up password
riley gilmore he's our guest today i'm
gonna use the bathroom just kidding
he's out hans kim is in everybody you
give it up for your guests hans kim
everybody party time i'm gonna use the
bathroom
this is actually also han's kim's
podcast that i'm split we're we're going
to splice it
then we're here with justin
what the [ __ ] did you say it's so sad
when you're with me dude i don't know
justin
he's just tired of you you did the same
thing you guys see each other we're here
with justin essenmaker everybody justin
s and macron instagram justin smacker
going through it you can listen to his
podcast if you want to um i know you
already did probably too much to click
on this one
but yeah come make a couple more clicks
and
listen to justin's where it's
the exact same as mine it's called
busting with justice busting
busting with justice you guys want
cliffing with justin welcome with the
queefs with justin podcaster we watch
porn together it's queefing with queen
latifah queen queefs with leaf tifa
everybody i'm i'm your
i'm your host queen latifah welcome to
queef welcome to queef vision we're
gonna get real close into the queefs
having a good time we're back we're back
home
we're having a good time we've been home
all weekend we we came down here we were
all booked on the same gig we didn't
really know it then hans got a weekend
at
dallas comedy club and he killed it a
lot of people came out we all got it
thursday i think like 200 people showed
up to the show right yeah it was like
700 people seven easily fifty probably
seven fifty probably close to eight
hundred probably nine it was sold out
like too many people like we didn't even
have enough chairs but we did it
yeah no chairs right there wasn't enough
enough carpet for all the people no
chairs is gonna be a motif this weekend
from my understanding
no chairs to queefin
no cheers
no cheers
um i mean this was an awesome weekend of
comedy because we did the shows at night
and then we got stood up by girls
after that and then in the daytime
in the daytime we did podcasts all day
don't speak for yourself about the women
thing me and phillip are fine we got
some women waiting for
that's not fair it's like yeah so we
watched yeah you guys stood up by your
women because they didn't even come with
you yeah dude and then you got set up by
a bat we really haven't
we built our own
she was not a bad she was a wrinkly
leather couch yeah if you guys yeah if
you guys don't know uh hans kim's type
dude i'll look at dracula and you'll
you'll see exactly what he goes imagine
cruella deville if she was 40 years
older
i love that i love that hans is laying
down and it's like he's like this is how
long we've been podcasting
this is now about how comfortable you
can get and keep going we're like
exiting this podcast soon it's just
gonna be us sleeping and that's going to
be the podcast soon enough we're all
going to be down to zero followers
people are just gonna be like i'm so
tired of getting annoying yeah
i honestly if you go live on instagram
more than twice a week you get
unfollowed for me really
yeah unless i know you unless i see you
every day
because live they put it right up up
front and in your stories so you don't
like that no i don't i get notified and
i've turned it off i don't know how to
get it keep it from coming up but every
time someone goes live they're like hey
phillip
we know you want to watch it it's in
your little heart section or does it
give you a little push note dude it
gives you a push notification and then
you get excited like somebody liked your
[ __ ] and it's like no someone's going
live snoop dogg watching your gps that
you're at home on the toilet here's a
live because we know you've never gotten
that before you'd never get live
notifications yeah oh
yeah well he could turn that off
only ones i really watch like
religiously or like regularly probably
david lucas because he roasts people on
there that's actually pretty funny right
yeah
and that's like a good actual random
format because like people just pop in
and he flames their ass real quick and
then he's done
that's awesome
yeah he found a way to make the platform
work for him does he turn on badges
i don't know what's that would you like
comment or if you turn on badges people
can buy you a badge and then it's just
like a way for you to get money that's
pretty dope yeah i'm sure he does i'm
sure you've monetized
wouldn't that be awesome to just get
paid for like this making fun of people
yeah
i mean that's what we
do
right but like just more directly like
on your phone you just turn on your
phone and just be like oh look at this
[ __ ] he has like weird ears
people give you money
dude i like to get the bases [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i mean i don't i don't think that we
should let the liberals have that one
the liberal agenda is always out to get
me personally
me personally like casey rockets
mentality
he's like yeah the left hates
basic things i need to do
to make myself feel good
casey rocket for president
[ __ ] stand up comedy that's this is not
his calling it's politics clearly
yeah he's a he's the most political
comedian
she is this is our new sponsor everybody
it's a
tech star cbd
tech star cbd get almost as high as you
smoking real weed
yeah at least they sell them real flour
it comes out
it's crazy i mean just
uh like see how fast we're talking now
and then compare it with about 10
minutes from now and you'll see that we
didn't get high at all i see that we
stopped a swarm of mosquitoes from
eating us alive i know i'm still itching
for that no kidding i'm not gonna at the
beginning of your past i had
i had a booger the size of the type like
titanic broke it in half people were
jumping off of it it was terrible that's
disgusting you just said that
stop
free the nipple
he was referencing that my mom hates
that word
here's the remote
but um
yeah i mean the awesome comedy scene
strong
[Laughter]
casey rocket
oh yeah no we really do have a strong
scene
i know a bunch of really funny head
chickens with their heads cut off
yeah yeah some wild kids we are we are
but what i respect about it and i think
the like i was you know being back home
i'm like wow there's 10 clubs in dfw now
that's appealing as [ __ ] but at the same
time i'm like
i'm around people all the time who are
constantly dedicating themselves to like
putting out [ __ ]
yeah the content side of it not even
just like content is like but like just
writing
buried in their notes there's people who
do that here in dfw too no doubt but in
austin it's just like ever present
everyone's
there's a hustle culture right but every
it seems like everyone's trying to
achieve that a higher level there
they're like everyone's there chasing a
bigger dragon yeah because austin is a
hot new thing dallas is the same right
like austin it's new people are moving
there everyone moved there recently yeah
that we hang out with it's still young
though there's still a very young scene
you know yeah yeah but we're trying to
make it into that next thing so that's
why i think it is growing because people
are excited about it
yeah there's an energy this is new we're
figuring it out anything can happen
we're trying to make it so crazy this is
now the 300th podcast to mention how
thriving austin's comedy scene is it's
just we're just so caught up in the
energy of it it's like the city that you
live in
has an effect on you it's been a weird
city and everyone keeps referring to it
as a social experiment which is really
accurate and what's crazier is i feel
lols
i feel times where i'm like
what is going on and then it turns back
around you're like everybody's out again
and it's like
hullabaloo yeah
and then it like kind of goes back down
it's just like there's it's weird in
austin yeah i read recently that there's
people believe there's like a lithium
cloud around austin and that's why
people get so like
crappy lucky and goofy there
i mean that might be the case but i
don't think that needs to be the case
every city has its own little patois
and
you can create a cool petois by doing
certain things to make everything cool
like encourage creative people
yeah riley said he had a pee
i think he's talking to your mom every
time this kid goes away gets lost
they have a connection
but riley really does like
he is a hardcore wanderer dude last
night like on the way when we were at
bedford ice house and this
motherfucker's getting in the car me and
justin have had drinks
riley has had half of a pbr
i threw my last beer down by the way
because i was just so [ __ ] limited
with being there
oh hey what did you choose it was just
like so much should have stacked up
didn't you swear at everyone yeah two
old men these two huff is the best way
to put it two old men were like my
brother's actually standing there can
you move but like you're just like so
aggressive about it i was like hey we're
leaving everyone's a piece of [ __ ] here
and then we left
well riley loved it there he was dancing
with cougars riley stuck around
afterwards to clear the air up a little
bit
respect because usually he was a
diplomat
it says you're a hardcore wanderer
what do you mean like when you go off
like you're gone bro
i feel like whenever you leave you might
i don't expect you to come back anytime
soon
me
yes sir no i mean uh
home is where the heart is i think
and uh
i'll i'll come back home
i'm coming home
uh but i i mean
what what does that mean like at a party
yeah
i really wasn't like i wasn't fixated on
it i just said like you do like you you
take you take your time well i like to
say hi to everyone you're not a wonder
you're a mozier
right
a lolli gag
lolly gag is is a derogatory term i'd
say like most of i guess moseying could
be too but
you do lollygag
i like to stick around and see what i
find
um but i mean i really want to be good
at dancing and i feel like
i'll never be good at dancing this is
i'm sorry that you got so hurt
i don't know how to two-step i don't
know how to one-step i don't know any
steps
i mean you are a good job
everyone is good at dancing deep down no
some people are very very bad i you know
what last night i was literally last
night i was invited into like you know a
group dance circle a swinger circle no
no like it was just like a bunch of kids
who were just like yeah you get in the
cir you get in the circle like and i
dance no it was a bunch of 65 year old
no no no no no no no no no i didn't have
a video no these were kids
and uh no no no no you don't understand
it was like retirement home bedford ice
house night a lot of them were very old
and and honestly and honestly
for for justin to say that about like me
dancing
i'm with old people and he still thinks
i'm bad at dancing so what does that say
about my dancing you're just like very
like
like
you're chill man i wouldn't say you're a
bad dancer look i i mean i i don't have
to be the [ __ ] fonz up there like i i
just need yeah don't listen to justin
because justin is the
pinnacle of any dance floor he steps on
he goes the [ __ ] off i'll give him that
when we would go to vulcan and dance for
edm [ __ ] like when we got drunk that
[ __ ] is like the life of a whole
edm show
damn see yeah that's i feel like that's
what i want to be but that's what you
feel like you want to be but some people
dude you just have to do it your own way
you can't do it his way you just got to
get yeah i do do it in my own way you
know i was i i danced with quite a few
uh
sexy mamas you danced with one woman
that was taken
and she was she was okay and then you
danced with one other woman put himself
out there and that's the most important
thing thank you he did put himself out
there you gotta face yourself out there
and see what the universe gives you and
sometimes it's an old dingbat our
waitress like shot him down like i
danced with a crazy old philippe
filipino
riley's like a golden retriever he's
gonna go up to everyone
and you know what a lot of people did a
lot of people liked me and a lot of
people did not like me but a lot of
people liked me yeah but not live in
fear not to shatter your your self-image
but
i can't tell
with a lot of comics you meet you're
like wow this isn't a character this is
a real human being like this is just how
that person is
and this weekend
i finally learned because i've only like
i know y'all i'm passing at open mics
and like around the scene
and then like this week and you get to
know someone a little longer i'm like
hans is hans is still pretty like i've
gotten to talk with you a couple long
times longer like riley i've always
wondered i'm like is he [ __ ] with me
what are you doing now i'm like exactly
right like yeah now i know like right
because then because then we say that
[ __ ] and then he's like wait what are
you what are you talking about and it's
like the things i just said and he's
like you know what you're talking what
do you mean
[Laughter]
we're like we just said what we meant
and he's like what do you mean like
literally
we just said it but he gives you moments
of clarity he sounds so like aloof and
like not with it
but then he then then he has his moments
and i'm like he's fun i like him and
he's funny but he's just so lost in his
own little world that's hilarious he's
like you can find when he's lost he's
like i'm gonna i'm in a maze right now
and i can't get out and then all of a
sudden he sees you and he's like i'm
back
i'm back to reality i don't really i
mean i love that look hey guys hey guys
i got lost for a little bit we're at
well you know when i'm back with a
vengeance in my mind
always firmly planted in reality no no i
disassociate too yeah especially when
he's thinking about kyle rittenhouse
yeah
um actually most times when i do that
when i'm staring off it's not traceable
back but like i was able to yes like i'm
podcast i'm able to because i can like
i'm listening to it happen in the
background there are times bro where
i'll just like
check out for like slack draw for like a
solid five minute they call me out at
all the time
what what oh yeah
what someone i didn't notice i did it
until someone in the austin comedy scene
told me they're like phil you know you
disassociate pretty frequently all the
time and i was like i don't know what
that means and they were like it means
like you check out and i was like i just
thought i was thinking that's just you
coming out of your sugar high
it's like damn i went to a diabetic coma
right here
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i shouldn't hate the whole bag of m
m's basically i ate a whole bag you're
just concentrating on getting blood to
your big toe
[ __ ] i got that limp again
i got to i can't feel my toes basically
i'm worried about that shooting pain
i'm like [ __ ]
dude he does that philip will ask you a
question he'll literally like ask you a
question
and you're like think for like a second
and then he goes into his phone and he
starts looking at his phone and you
answer him and he doesn't reply and i'm
like
what and then he like sits there and i'm
like dude what the [ __ ] and he's like
yeah what and i'm like you just asked me
a question i've been talking to you for
five minutes i call that high spawning
it's like once
someone asks you a question you're like
you don't want to say anything but they
ask you a question in your head so like
30 minutes later you're like
i don't think i said that to you my
powerful thoughts were you're going to
feel my thoughts they're so strong
sometimes you can though
right
be like yeah despite a look on your face
someone's coming up someone whistling
hey
sit on down enjoying the with philip get
up dude
you wanna mike cousin vinnie
yeah dude get in on this
get in the mirror wanna hop in the pod
bro
the water's fine
water feel nice nobody knows what it's
like water is to be the sad man
give that mic a test real quick
oh it's not gonna be on our channel
though
[Music]
okay that makes it better i guess even
though there's no way we're going to be
able to hook it up
why can't we hook it up it's a tragedy
honestly
[Music]
hey did you talk about how riley tried
to kill himself last night on a bonfire
pit
yes
it's pretty dangerous
dude you're a daredevil wait so like but
not really on this file will the file
have the imprinted audio from the
nice so i won't have to like clamp it
that's dope
yeah you don't even need to record it
but you can if you want okay sweet
um
should we talk about sex in the city i
mean i feel like we've been
displaying this poster the whole time
okay let's do sex in the city of which
character would you be i don't know
definitely i don't know either i'm the
hot one let's not do it you're the hot
one what's the hot one to using there's
a gay one
oh
was that on purpose yeah i [ __ ] hate
that stupid [ __ ] poster wanna bring
the star wars poster and then
oh watch that watch out dude you [ __ ]
that up oh [ __ ] all right hans is gone
bye hans
hey can i have that wizard's flag up
there that soccer poster philip that's
fine no that's my like that's my
we're changing them out
oh [ __ ]
oh now it's a nerd podcast it's always
been a podcast it's a glare podcast oh
[ __ ]
dude my stomach just growled so loud we
look like we're having like a
a worship
glare
oh [ __ ] the glare witch project that's
what i'm just saying
oh [ __ ]
still glared
this looks like a
[ __ ] funeral put that put that light
on the ground hey put that light on the
ground what's going on with that why is
it moving so much
oh my god i was scared i couldn't see
your hands there you go
there's our idols it's terrifying
it's terrifying
dude riley you're kind of like c-3po
without like the smarts you know
the way he talks and [ __ ] he's like
what are we doing here
i do not know
riley we're doing a podcast what is a
podcast
that's cool
cp3 appeal knows everything though
how do you feel about getting so much
hate from justin all the time
um i think maybe because i remind him of
c-3po he kind of reminds me of myself i
feel like people treat me
through p.o yeah i treat riley like
people treat me and i'm sorry riley this
is some weird self self torture
experience i'm sorry yeah this is like
this feels like a like an artist riley
do people do people pick on you a lot um
no they don't so just me
no i didn't i didn't uh i didn't think
you were picking on me okay cool i feel
like i've always respected you riley
thanks man respect you too
yeah i respect you i respect you too
i uh
i think r-e-s-p-c-e-t
is gonna find out what we we we did for
each other
no fun of what it means to me
what does it mean to you but we both did
it what does it mean to you means to me
is like
um
sort of a glowing hope you know
this is gonna this is gonna be
where where
where
stop
um
texas pharmacy he's got more text what's
it called tech sports cbd with them
yeah texas pharmacy it seems like a that
seems like a like a drug dealer shirt
like
yeah this is my boy's uh this is my
boy's business it's his pharmacy
he's nothing you're not in the shot
he's all good he's okay
there's stuff over here if you want
there's ground up cbd right here oh yeah
and you can just put it in there
it's in the grinder
this is here i got you i'll just do it
for you
no problem
what you been up to man i just got off
work nice pick up that green microphone
it was the same thing
the same thing every day what's that
you're talking to it but you're not on
the camera
it's um
we just we're gonna kill we're gonna
work it's just like order processing and
stuff like that it's it's really boring
yeah
[ __ ]
where'd everybody go
riley's fixing the angles
he's cutting you out
oh my god
what'd you guys do
that's what we're talking about we've
done nothing all weekend really
we've done what most people would
consider nothing
that's what we've done
we did a show that one's not on
what are you doing tonight
sure
lg tap tj's lab
labs tj's
taps lj's taps lj's taps cheese taps
dab's going you should come
you should come hello hello hello it's
like 45 minutes hello
yeah
there's no chairs though right here
eddie kept saying there's no
chairs what do you think about how the
southern states haven't legalized
marijuana even though it's clearly the
right answer and would make their lives
so much better out of stubbornness
and uh
their need to be right all the time put
those headphones on
who are you asking he just he just gets
roped into a podcast due to a podcast
anyone
i think we're losing out on a lot of a
lot of money
word
preach dog we should take back the power
from the old people and have young
people rule the world
i think we should kill old people and
harvest their organs and that way
we do want an old person's organs we can
smoke pot for longer then
no because after you get there we'll
replace my 30 year old mom you're gonna
[ __ ] you're gonna get you're gonna
hit one puff of weed and die it's like
temporary pit patches though like
you're just gonna
[Music]
hey are you a healthy old person we're
gonna we're gonna take your organs i'm
breaking in but if you're dying we'll
just keep you alive
if you're a healthy old person we're
gonna kill you are old people's organs
like
done working or is it like mostly just
their heart that gives up because like
if their organs stop
a lot of organs stop
depending on their [ __ ] shuts down
that's why they [ __ ] start smelling
and [ __ ]
your tongue is in your mouth for 80
years
just getting old getting decaying but
like a fresh tongue a baby's tongue is
like it's new it's plushy
but an old time it's just been out in
the air in the sun oh that's just going
to make me close my mouth that made me
just that made me sick
just the old people's tongues the way
that you the way that you described the
tongue now i just thought of all of it
because it's like damn my tongue has
done a lot it's like a piece of beef in
your mouth
no it's like a dirty piece though and
then we think some toothpaste is good
and we're like i mean it cleans
but this tongue has been to some places
yeah it's been to space tongues in space
yeah open orifice like
that's that's that's you that's yeah
that's what you do that's how you drink
water show how you drink water dude
what's that tongue thing you do every
[ __ ] time philip drinks water dude he
does this he goes
like a dog [ __ ] thank you luke it's
[ __ ] nasty dude
how do you drink water dude i i actually
i drink water out kind of out of the
side of my mouth but yeah i like when it
touches my my two front teeth it's just
a little sensitive you know if it's cold
water interesting yeah i feel like i
find myself eating that way on the side
of your mouth yeah i drink beer i drink
like cans on the side of my mouth what
are you doing i don't notice that
exactly like this that's so good i drink
like on the side i don't know why
it's not because my teeth are sensitive
i'm not a [ __ ] you're just a game i'm
kidding you're just you're a gangster
like you know how they shoot with their
guns to the side
you drink from the side and you look
from the side you know it's a
sensitivity issue get it
it's like yeah see did you guys get my
joke
i thought it was a good one
said hans looks from the side
it that doesn't make sense my eyes are
small all the way it's like a crossbar
it doesn't make sense but we know that
because he mentioned your eyes that he
is indeed inside so like that makes
sense
you're like wasn't that funny how i said
i was racist right i didn't say how i
was just i didn't say hey wasn't that
funny i was racist i said you're you
look sideways it's not like dude racism
isn't that beholder it does it's like
beauty i've heard that a lot this
weekend
yeah when you're hanging out with philip
he's so racist all the time isn't the
eye of the beholder a few times this
weekend really i feel like i was the
first person to ever say and i felt
special for this beauty is in the eye
that the first person i ever said to say
that racism wasn't the eye of the
beholder
yeah i i think i heard it from somewhere
else though i don't know and how did it
make you feel riley's in the eye of my
ass
your ass has an eye yeah my brown eye
hey rod you ever looked at a brown eye
has it winked back
um
yeah we had a staring contest
i i feel like i really feel like uh
i should start winking more though
dude seriously
that's what's missing
i think like it like if i could just
start saying y'all and winking
i think that would really be you're
going to be charged you can't can you
not wink
i can wink i just don't wake like
i always practice
like a like as like like a second grader
like uh all right okay
just like that was weird that's why it's
twitch
it is very crazy
i'm like
you know i mean
no a wink could be
not creepy
doing the wink not when you do it riley
all right how about this
let me finish
i i'm like looking at a girl i'm like
okay yes
um
yeah it's good but it's just weird that
that's all you think your personality
needs is like these little flourishes at
the end and now some deep changes
hans are you a good like flirter it is
[Music]
no i mean i think it'll be good honestly
you just want to get in under their skin
how do you get how do you
introduce yourself to a woman like how
does it go how do you feel hey uh don't
you think that yeah i found your heart
the whole system of us trying to talk to
each other is stupid like dating
let's do it but it's so stupid
at the same time that we're doing it
too aware of what that's what you say to
a woman yeah i'm like i'm talking to you
but i really think i'm better than you
damn it's the most honest thing you
could say
exactly louis c.k said like what else do
you say to him and that's on like the
only honest thing you could say to
opening a bar is like i want to put my
penis in the lowest hole in your face
ears no how about
eyes
okay
i'll give you a nostril if you give me a
one huh
what if uh what if she's talking in one
of those with like the hole in their
neck that's the neck it's not the face
but i don't really know your face
there's only one hole in the face right
well there's one two three the lowest
holes i mean that i would want to put my
dick in do you guys know if you drill a
hole in your head you get stuck you can
say hi forever
hi
i also heard this lots of blood it's
true what are you talking about though
if you drill a hole in your head it's
supposed to like activate a chemical
where you can stay high forever
just any hole anywhere no i think it's
like a special thing different places
for different drugs like could i do it
right here
don't do it can i do like can i do like
three whiskey sodas and like two joints
perfect amount all the time
like one of those hats that you wear you
know like i'll take a third hole uh
i've only had three holes tonight so i'm
just getting started
i think i don't think i'm ready for a
fourth hole tonight i'm gonna go home
i'm gonna call it quits tonight come on
come on up come out with the buddies
we'll have a few holes
play a few holes
get some holes
it's gonna be a holy night look at all
swiss cheese steve he's really just off
his hand
he's really gone tonight
it's just a good old dimple face steve
it's just a convertible up there
his whole head's gone
looks like he walked through a hell
store yeah dude
he's like honey don't end up like that
guy
he took one of his eyes away to have
that extra hole
now i call him one eye jimmy now they
call him always high jimmy why is
everyone at the church so holy
so this is why you stay in rileyland so
long it's because you have these
fanciful
ideas about holes and heads and you just
earlier
we
well yeah i mean it's just like funny
it's just like it's crazy to like say
that about a thing it's like oh that's
just a funny bone like why even like
have a name for it because it's easy to
hurt i think that's actually the reason
it's probably name this irony dude yeah
we always need some irony here it's like
like i ironed my shirts oh that's your
funny bone
what's the phone i guess yeah
yeah i mean uh everybody laughs when it
happens to the person too there has to
be something everybody laughs in the
room because the person because you know
how it hurts so when they do it you're
like oh that hurt didn't it and
everybody's like yeah it [ __ ] did
take your pain seriously yeah yeah it's
a it's such a weird type of pain though
but like if you get hit in the face
everybody's like oh [ __ ] it's not funny
maybe like shaking it feels funny though
maybe that's what it is it's funny but
painful also like if you get like a
charlie horse yeah
like
oh my god i hate when charlie the horse
comes up and kicks i feel more like a
richard every time i don't know why they
were named it that right it should be
called the richard horse sad bone
uh dick face horse
you ever got the charlie horse
underneath your uh chin
no yes right here you open your mouth a
little too wide and then it's you've
never done it like uh yeah you've never
had a charlie horse your muscles get
tired from opening too big
who's naming these like
these like symptomatic
injuries
clearly a farmer that one's a watermelon
why do you say clearly a farmer that's
your funny bone
well he looks like he we got you got
yourself a charlie horse we got him we
got one like that that limps around on
the farm ah yeah i could see you being a
farmer i could see it being a fan i feel
so [ __ ] when i walk i'm walking like
charlie's horse right now
that's great yeah
that's what's going on that's why it
happened uh yeah
it'd be funny if we just learned that
farmers like just named every word
like that's probably where a lot of it
came from the controller daylight
savings
media daylight savings man almanac just
kind of weird because
people are working 24 hours around the
clock anyways now so
yeah what is time kind of an ancient
practice time isn't it right yeah it
only fights it only favors people who
wake up early like people who stay up at
five which is everyone
like everyone stays up it wakes up at
five not everyone wakes up at six a.m so
you're getting more daylight in the
morning
to reward like five percent of the
population that wakes up at that time
right
it's like does that mean you think we'll
ever get to a world eventually that
doesn't have deadlines
because
the only thing that's keeping it in now
is like what banking
financial institutes
and deadlines like the need to get
things done with no time i mean it's
just like yeah we need it before that
sun comes up again
[Laughter]
how many moons until i had till i have
this done
i'll give you three moons
to have this finished tonight pay me
back in 17 alpha centauris how that
started like farmers were just like
everybody turned their lights off
and there's just like they're just being
dicks you think it just caught on i said
turn it off greg
you have to go to sleep
i'm going to change it up tomorrow
everyone's at the bar so it's closed no
it's not it's closed right now no it's
not it's only one a.m guys
i have [ __ ] lettuce to pick tomorrow
can you guys just stop do you think
that's what they made their first ground
was at bars they're like how are we
gonna get this started no one's gonna be
on our side they're like we go to bars
we tell them that they can drink for an
extra hour and then we celebrate it
every like two times they did it so they
woke up earlier to farm fields yeah but
not everyone was even a farmer back then
too yeah but the biggest thing back then
was farming and everybody was farming
absolutely i guess i don't know why i
think it's because the way in the world
of all the people the way the earth
shifts all the people that can change
their time schedule i think it'd be
farmers it's not like the chickens care
what time you come
yeah they're like damn bro it's early
i feel like it affects me wait that's a
good question though riley does
right does it happen to the entire world
though
i don't know does it oh 5 pm grain
harvesting that's the producer to find
it
dude because if it doesn't we're just
[ __ ] with our time you can't do that
you can't [ __ ] with time morty
if you seriously are dude where you
can't just play with time like that i'll
do daylight savings
dude that's probably having like a
ripple effect where we're just like yeah
we're all [ __ ]
i'm actually 45 years old maybe that's
what it is dude yeah what's my body
feels terrible honestly maybe i'm
actually like let's try the cigarettes i
feel like [ __ ]
it must be the government i do look old
as [ __ ] recently what's crazy to me is
like how time works that you can fly
away like you can go to mars and come
back and then somehow
you're younger than everybody else yeah
if you go faster time is slower right
because but it's just weird that that
actually affects aging because you think
like okay despite times
time depends on velocity and
acceleration
right time isn't just this thing that's
always the same it's the relative theory
of relativity but to think you can go on
a mission and come back i don't know be
gone for three years or like 40 years on
earth and then come back and only age
like four or five years
i heard this experiment a thought
experiment where if you're on a train
and you bounce the ball up and down
then it only covers this amount of
distance but if you're watching from
outside the ball goes like this because
the train is moving so it covers more
distance but the velocity of light is
the same and the time and the sp and the
distance is different so the time has to
be that's the most clear way i've heard
it but yeah right
crazy but um that's just going fast
though it's a really good explanation
for something that i've never heard of
for time travel i'm more lost now i'm
like the ball it makes total sense but
uh if you're watching from outside the
pain or train playing the ball the ball
is making like
but if you're watching inside it's just
going like up and down oh so if you're
going faster then time is going faster
but if you're going slower
time is going slower
damn
it's like when you hear a song raising
in pitch when you when it's driving away
you're like yeah is that song you're
like hearing time like warp
yeah
sound waves
daylight saving time is super unpopular
here are the countries that don't do it
so the answer is no so those are places
that are ahead then arizona doesn't do
it yeah arizona doesn't do it i think
it's the only state what the [ __ ] then
so they can just do time differently
yeah there's no there's no farming and
arrows no rules there is no farming in
there there's like a junior
hey how about next year we just take it
five hours a week riley the government
the government is trying to take our
time and i want to [ __ ]
wake up whenever i want i have a
constitutional right to bear time
we talked about this last night though a
time conspiracy that like this daylight
savings hit so hard and like even right
now it's like four it's like i think
they're snipping a little bit off the
end every time so it's like an hour one
minute and then over the time like
they've stolen three hours from us i'm
saying the sun really used to rise what
is it gonna do with all this time six in
the morning like the sun used to rise
rule time you rule the world from us
what are these our systems we're going
to go who owns it time warner movie in
time whoa dude that's a crazy movie i
think so
where you just like have like one hour
left yeah
yeah like that justin timberlake movie i
like that justin timberlake movie he's
like his mom is running out of time she
doesn't have enough money
in his arms you know yeah
he just had to transfer
they don't have wireless transfer they
have to touch each other
i have venmo they don't have venmo they
can't just be like here's some time no
they do they
oh they don't have they'll have phones
but
they don't have venmo but they got time
as well so you can buy time
yeah by going out of space with time
whoa dude
we should go into outer 10 000 bucks in
a bank account and then like flew mars
in back real quick
dude that's so sad man
dude that would be the worst if you flew
into outer space and then you come back
and then everything is just like way
older like everyone know when you knew
yeah everybody was dead a lot of money
that doesn't matter anymore
hey yeah we changed the currency as soon
as that would be so crazy man but i'm
like a billionaire
yeah not now you're just poor
thanks for your mission now you're poor
and irrelevant and no honestly
yeah really go write a book kill
yourself
people actually forgot you were up there
yeah dude we didn't even we didn't even
actually need that mission after like
five years we figured it out on the
ground they're like oh yeah
my bad i forgot to text you
[ __ ]
we don't text anymore we actually we we
plug into our horse's butts with our
penis well you look great you know
you look really young for 90.
well you look great
[Laughter]
your kids are 45 and you're still like
thrilled yeah your kids are dead they're
dead too yeah
you look great though
your newborn
oh yeah your wife actually just died in
a car accident they were only like 25.
it was crazy
but you look great your kids are dead
you're actually a baby now but
yeah
are you all ready for this show tonight
no you're excited
let me tell you let me tell you why you
should be excited it's going to take us
42 minutes to get there shut the [ __ ] up
let me tell you why you should be dude i
hate this city no offense
what you mean is you hate these cities
yeah it's just a mechanics why is it
just a collection of cities everyone's
car is going to break down eventually
the world is a collection of cities i
mean no but dfw is like 50 cities
yeah
but like this is definitely to the max
we're traveling to a whole other city
hills keller's white settlements saginaw
blue mountain [ __ ] nuts we could fit
the 700 new yorks in dallas yeah
and instead you just have parking lots
of emptiness and
highways usw airport is bigger than
manhattan island
that's
ridiculous right there's a train
for the airport
for you to go to the next terminal
wow do you live in the east airport
no i'm actually more like southeast
airport yo i'm from
i'm from lower east side airport
it's funny you say that but like on the
north side of the airport is i'm from
the bronx of the airport south lake it's
south lake on the south side of the
airport is
irving which is not south lake
damn i don't i have to go into the
airport south lake is nice you could
live there like tom hanks did in the
terminal
i'm sure people do
i mean
we have the money to build this
monstrosity
so
our powers are better than our ability
to organize
hmm hey you know what mom's getting you
for christmas
what mom's getting you a hotel room for
you and ava to come down to uh austin
is that is that already like agreed upon
or yep i told her i was like that's
funny that's like you're getting him
more time with me
you get you get to he looks so sad about
it
you just ruined the surprise that was
like it just seems like it seemed like a
riley gift for a second dude
it seemed like a reilly gift
i'm sure it'll be fun man
[Laughter]
do you like to get [ __ ] up
yeah yeah yeah i like to do do you like
la quintas
you like so much
i want like a good breakfast with my
hotel you know oh man yeah breakfast
did you did you not the hotel no hotel
breakfasts are [ __ ] right now because
yeah
oh really hotel breakfast is never
really that great oh they're not great
they were cool because you can make your
own waffles it's just free texas shaped
waffles man i've been to some that were
like those are so good it's the texas
shape belgium waffles
it's just it tastes like texas yeah i
don't know that's just a way to save on
waffle batter you think
because that's not a perfect circle as a
kid i had these mickey mouse waffles and
they were so good like
i agree like it is a shape because i'd
eat the ears first it's gonna be like a
fun thing like that's like four or five
years ago was when you were doing this
actually i bought them in the frozen
section last night they were really good
um you can make your mouth mickey mouse
is probably yeah they have mickey mouse
but no they're not frozen
all the mickey mouse pancake is there's
a pancake with two mistakes yeah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh look it's a mouse
you start like star pancakes and you
guys remember when pancake art was a big
thing yeah on tech talk yeah yeah i mean
it's not like i do it all the time in my
free time
i could eat some pancakes right now i'm
so hungry it's one step up from
cappuccino art
yeah i think cappuccino artisan
cappuccino is really impressive man
but it's a limited meat like renaissance
things in the in the coffee
like
michelangelo is my barista like
and then that's what i was just talking
about we're all these over qualified
individuals and we're just like we have
michelangelo level art like digital
artists and they're like what are you
doing i make a really really beautiful
espresso
it's like yeah i mean i just do that
like as an extra thing but my main thing
is coffee
but like i just kind of like do an extra
like quick like artistic like genius
painting and then but like my mind
thinks coffee though
yeah what's it gonna everyone's uber
everyone's gonna be an uber he said you
guys have a bit that our economy is
gonna end up where you're either the
person making the food the person
delivering the food or the person
ordering the food and it's just going to
be a self-serving i'm going to be the
person eating that's what it is that's
what it is i'm going to be the food you
might be dude well that's the best taste
that's the best way to do it man
you might get a what if dude that's what
the shot is that's what
sentience and then they're like
they have pride in how tasty they are
and they're like these bros that always
work out like i'm gonna be the tastiest
i'm actually putting a little bit more
fat back towards the glutes because
brisk i'm gonna make pretty good brisket
one day yeah i'm gonna be like cal
ripken junior uh he's my hero cow
he fed obama
obama said it was the best meal gordon
ramsay says my dad was the tastiest
my uncle said he's having tea mascot
your mom is like get up you have a life
to not
get live it warren buffett is gonna
isn't gonna like you if you don't work
out today
you're gonna be murdered someday start
acting like it that's not gonna be
reveal if you don't
[Laughter]
you can take the young one he's not
really trying you don't want to end up
like
he's not primate beef make him feel you
don't
some dairy cattle riley
why do i want to even live yeah well you
can go die today jimmy you can go right
to the butcher you want to go to the fog
the rest of your life that's what
they're gonna say yeah you can take my
[ __ ] of a daughter she has big
knockers milk her out
you think dairy cows would just be like
the bottom level or
no that would be the hot [ __ ] very
good they're guys like queen latifah and
uh yeah dude i'm dating becky dude she's
in dairy
my milkshake brings all these bulls to
the yard they're like i'm gonna die
before yours
let's all be different let's all get on
all fours right now and act out
like the cows let's do human centipede
right now
stitch each other ourselves just [ __ ] in
my mouth is this live no [ __ ]
no it's not live
someone else have you ever played that
game where you're just like
no what game is that
that's the game
[Music]
put me put it in my poo poo
moo moo how's it go again do it one more
time maybe i missed it the first time it
was like i was like
like
[Music]
and everybody was looking at you calling
you a mo
mo
yeah hey mom like someone else like uh
like uh you got a milk milk's the others
and then what was the game was this your
uncle or a priest or friends at
school my uncle
we sick ragers with like these like
local priests and like my uncles
did they bring wine and [ __ ] wine and
bread hey guys it brought the wine and
bread yeah i mean i also brought my dick
no we're not [ __ ] the thing about
beer i mean the thing about wine is when
you wake up the next morning your
[ __ ] really hurts
yeah
uh
yeah they party hard priests
yeah oh yeah part of the job are they
chill dude what about it um then i mean
they're just like reckless like smoke
weed
pretty lit dude nah pretty much
exclusively wine and ketamine
have you played the mafia game
which one yeah it's a fun game head down
and then they're like mafia raise your
hand or look up yeah you're talking
about
heads up seven
up yeah this one is different because
there's angels
there's cops
so the mafia chooses one person to kill
you ever played cowboys and you can kill
people that no you have interpersonal
relationships with
that's not i've never heard that
mafia yeah it's fun it's like a group
it's a fun game did you ever play mr
president or anything like that
it's where you like hold uh where do you
get everyone's in an agreement
and like one person starts it you put
like two ears up to your ear like you're
a bodyguard for mr president
and then the last person to notice it in
the group like once everyone realizes
there's one person who hasn't you all
tackle them and you start yelling mr
president get down
um so you're trying to hurt the
president
yeah basically hey can you play that
could you play the mafia game right now
what about
telephone would be funny you want me to
start it yeah
[Music]
phrase like give me liberty or give me
death or like
okay hasta
okay
also say it to the microphone should we
make it a little bit longer though since
there's only what five of us just do do
whatever you need just say it to the
microphone
stand
[Laughter]
[ __ ] your ears
[Music]
yeah i think it's too easy
unless he just butchers and says
something
what is it you [ __ ] really whispered
it
some types of virgins die
holy [ __ ] dude
that's nice holy [ __ ] what did you say i
said uh to live or to die that's what i
said that's what i said i said but then
philip looked at me and he goes
i [ __ ] it up maybe i [ __ ] it up
riley did [ __ ] he goes
off maybe
oh
well maybe i was trying to make it
harder maybe i was like trying to like a
little
bit you made it interesting so i guess
you achieved it but now they know that
because like
i don't know
so riley just sabotaged the whole game
i thought it was so easy i thought he
was getting kicked in apart
phillips like this guy sounds like a
virgin
what other game philip
let's do some ad libs
oh my god five minutes of it is you're
gonna be like adjective no
plural no
that'd be funny and then riley would be
riley would be confused he'll be like
what's what yeah what are those that is
what
what's an adjective actually i don't
know what it is true you already used
trees
you know what it is [ __ ] did you look
up a mad lib i was kidding what
might have been funny no that's what it
is it's like so much setup where you're
just thinking of words and then you're
reading it and you're like
i said that
i remember when i thought of that we
could look up good news that's always
fun
good news i know good news i do did you
guys hear about kyle rittenhouse he was
found not guilty wait a minute kyle
writtenhouse he's an american hero
he killed white people so he's a hero
man i've been hearing about it all week
dude how could you how would you feel
killing your own kind
yeah you gotta kill
foreign garbage patch holy mother of god
it worked
is what someone said
that's how much trash 20 000 pounds
that's a lot of people in the dfw
they've been trying this new thing
there's twenty thousand pounds of white
trash in my neighborhood so yeah that's
right
and that's just six houses that's just
your mama
that's a great your mama joke
what happened to the art of your mom
your mama
yeah like i'll sing all good things they
die
like all good mamas
that are too fat they pass away early
like that movie gilbert grape
where they had to burn their mom
what
yeah they had to burn their mom why
she was so fat yeah they they she died
in the house and couldn't get her out so
they burnt the house
they couldn't just wait
no hydrate her like jerky
they burnt her
drain her blood this week is also
national family week everybody and
that's all i have to say about this oh
hey the news did you hear the woman
president thing for 85 minutes that was
news i mean 85 minutes yep joe biden got
[ __ ] in the ass for 85 yeah yeah he
got a colonoscopy by all right that's
why right kamala harris was like what do
you think kamala harris did in those 85
launch the missiles probably changed
tick-tock
she probably watched biden tick-tock
what'd you say she did change her tampon
she was having her period
how come how come he got put out for a
colonoscopy is that that's routine
that's what they told that's what he
told us
he was totally awake for him you know he
likes it he did it himself you got to
get one
yeah i can do it myself
can do it myself everyone should get a
corn oscar we have to get one in a
couple months
i should just come in when he's sleeping
and stick something up his ass right i
don't have i don't have health insurance
how am i going to cool and ask do they
put you out for a job
i didn't know you had to put robots to
sleep to do surgery i didn't know robots
were allowed in my [ __ ] that's all
i'm saying i didn't know i
didn't sign up for that colonoscopies
is it an 85 minute procedure well you
get put out so yeah putting out is
probably most of it do it the way i do
it
you're sedated that you got a good
prepped for that the way i do it it's
weeks long
stick around there for months
do they lose colonoscopies are supposed
to be a fun thing where i'm from go out
for dinner together
get to know that man
intimately we've been doing this podcast
for an hour i know this machine that's
not a lot
for how long an hour
and then probably another hour for the
one before it you want to try to break
the record i'm just i'm just going to
notate it here how long do you think the
world's longest podcast has been too
long couple days right yeah
honestly if we talked about the austin
comedy scene we could probably do about
three days so we could talk about any we
know so much [ __ ] dude creek in the cave
great
anything we could talk as long as we
want we could talk for the rest of our
lives what's your favorite part of this
there's always things to also
it's your favorite
what's your favorite part of the austin
comedy scene uh it's gotta be cm
smokehouse
yeah
it's hard to talk about it because
you're afraid of offending people
especially on a podcast but i hope that
no one knows that like
i genuinely meant that like i think that
my favorite part of the awesome comedy
scene is that was the best part is food
and not the comedy yeah
you do you see you're talking to
no the best part about the austin comedy
scene is gonna be uh
right now i think it's uh comet comic
produced shows
yeah i think i think that's the worst
part i think it's the community down
there i like the community
yeah
i don't know like as a viewer um when i
go to like comedy shows and stuff like
that i like to see him produced by
comedians you know rather than
some dude making money off of uh
people he's not really paying you know
does that help you laugh easier uh
yeah maybe
because then you don't feel like you're
laughing at a wall there's less rules
yeah
someone with some corporate comments
right whatever it may be right
right yeah it's more authentic books
actually
a comic watching yeah in austin right
now i'd say like 85 percent of the shows
are booked by a comic that's really dope
dude but the thing is like people like
we also know that like we we bomb all
the time like we're not like speak for
yourself dude
you shouldn't bomb at shows
it happens if everyone does it but like
the idea but like
have you been like maryland i i can only
be
i can only be so funny dude i'm not like
uh i'm not like a professional like i
haven't done this that long like yeah
don't tell yourself don't tell them that
um well they know that they know that
they don't have to do a job
but like but it is true though like
because i don't i'm not i i'm not that
good at it
i'm not even like well don't think that
you're good at it
we should try to hide that as much as
possible
i should delete this right now fear try
to be better why dude you're
self-conscious about it hey guys you
want to show it i kind of suck at this
but stay with me on this sometimes i can
trick you guys sometimes you just have
to do it
yeah but don't be honest with the crowd
don't let them show don't show the crowd
that you don't know the [ __ ] i'm not
saying that's what i'm doing i'm saying
like i can like even if i'm trying
my hardest like it's not gonna be like
funnier than well if you think that it's
like i've always heard that when you're
on stage like especially like even
something that like patrice has said was
like you gotta pretend like you're the
baddest [ __ ] in that room yeah
because you gotta enjoy being yourself
like even if you don't think that you're
gonna have the best set like who you are
is interesting and you get to show these
people who you are what if who you are
is just like fundamentally boring though
that just is where the depression is
going to [ __ ] off any stage
don't waste our time dude shut up
you should ask that tonight uh that
should be your opening line
hey do you all like me
i wanna hey you guys like me i'm pretty
boring i might be fundamentally boring
i might be fundamentally [ __ ]
fundamentally hey it's fundamental
that's what my mom told me i'm funny
not funny i'm fundamentally saying funny
thing
i say funny things but i also don't try
so
deep down inside i can trick you for a
bit down inside i'm very sad i'm very
unfunny
it's amazing how
i'm not that funny
no i mean like that's like who you are
deep down inside is like such a
amorphous vague thing that it
you shouldn't define it as funny or
unfunny everyone's a serial killer
yeah
kinda
i don't know lizard brain dude
lizard brain
serial killers are like
um bad they just learned they're like
not chilling they just they like take
killers
i'm beginning to think these serial
killers are a bit psychopathic
i'm beginning to think they need to
calm down and eat a bowl of cereal
before they kill somebody next
yeah did you guys ever had some cereal
in your life i never told you that
you're angry
it's like you're obsessed with it
hey right before you kill someone do you
see their face and they're like hey man
don't do it and then you do it people
don't like that
people don't like when you do that
because we've been noticing recently at
parties you do this like serial killer
[ __ ]
where you take someone in the back and
like you stab him a few times and then
you come back to the party all bloody it
really throws the vibe off could you
stop
what do you want me to do at the party
it really makes like hang out you know
like it scares the girls if any of us
ever kill anybody in this services this
is going to be quite eerie
this can't be any this cannot be ever
commit like mass murder like serial kill
that's our services it'll be so eerie
that's an interesting thing no dude
because that would never happen well i
just watched this uh documentary about
the amazon review killer and he would
order his [ __ ] to kill and capture
people off amazon he would kill like
amazon
no and then he would review
the product who is he killing uh like uh
couples usually he would take advantage
of he apparently showed this is like
people this is like before they had
delivery drivers when you would meet no
he's killing people that he was a real
estate agent hey i need your help
clearing this
[ __ ] on my land and he'd have to where
does amazon come in he would he'd buy
the stuff to chain the women up in those
like shipping containers and he'd order
all of the equipment and [ __ ] to keep
him captive on amazon amazon but then he
would leave reviews on amazon
like about the equipment numerous
hangouts humorously saying like
really good if you're trying to lock a
[ __ ] up in a room for a couple months
holy [ __ ] yeah so he was using real
estate to do that he was doing it for
the amazon reviews were just a byproduct
what do you mean he wasn't using amazon
to kill people he was using his real
estate no i was just saying like he was
like elaborately saying
when it came back people were like oh
this guy is a convicted serial killer
and these are his amazon reviews yeah i
don't think that's what's happening now
i think that we're just talking about
serial killers because riley brought it
up i don't know i said it would be eerie
if if one of us
this podcast came up it would be eerie
to see it right but that sort of stopped
the riff don't you think
no i thought it was an interesting story
it's kind of sad i wanted to hear more
about the story i was really into it
what happened
he chained a woman up in a shipping
container for like two months and what's
crazy is like when they got her she was
completely like coherent and like was
able to tell the police immediately he
shot my husband three times in the chest
put him in a blue tarp took him in a
backhoe buried him in the back probably
did she get away yeah
yeah police rescued her how
they
how did they find out because amazon
drone that's another crazy thing he was
taking their cell phones and then
posting on their facebooks like they ran
away and that everything was completely
okay and they're just pinging it to this
dude's property
it took him two months to ping it
serial killers are just what an idiot
man he was kind of a
like a aloof but then he commits he had
uh he confesses to four other murders
at an atv shop where he killed everybody
in a blind rage just shot all the atv
employees dead
so yeah and then he committed to two
other that's pretty like a parent thing
do they have a case open
on it already and then you switch to e
it's not really a secret well they gave
up on that first case with the four dead
right it was it was uh so he's the
amazon killer because he left reviews
he's an amazon killer because he's also
a huge use to kill and hold people
captive he ordered from amazon and then
left reviews that were like yes but he
how did he lured the woman into the
shipping container or the husband and
the woman he told the woman through real
estate that see that's the thing he was
just called the review killer because he
was he like a real estate agent right
and he they were like facebook friends
of a friend and she saw his post that
was like i need help clearing brush on
my land
yeah
and so she took the opportunity yeah
anyone who says i need help clearing
brush on my land is definitely uh that's
the thing that's even weirder he's like
a pinnacle of the community he's like a
real estate agent he had a dog people
knew him as being he definitely brought
up serial killers
he's a good guy he has a dog you're like
serial killers are all about murders
even weirder he wouldn't rape him
remember he refused to rape i don't
think that that's i don't think that
that's weird
i mean the murder is the best part a
woman is shackled in a shipping
container
you feel like
sense of owner owning that or whatever
maybe he was uh asexual or a non-binary
yeah
seriously he was there for the kill he
didn't seem like a serial killer it
seems like he's just acting off uh rage
the victim said that even
if i didn't want to commit a sexual act
he never made me he made that very clear
that he'd never make me but he did make
it clear that if i didn't have a purpose
that i wouldn't he wouldn't have any use
for me and that he would kill me so i'm
like that's rape
still had sex did he have sex with her
yeah
that's how she stayed alive for two
months that's how she stayed alive for
two months yeah it's a gray area wow all
right
what was scary was the there's footage
of the rescue and they're like sawing
off with these big saws
five padlocks off the shipping container
so you're like this woman in a pitch
black shipping container chained up and
you have to sit there for 30 minutes and
listen to this screeching sound of metal
being chopped by metal
and then you gets opened and it's but
when you're in that kind of scenario you
get used to crazy sounds and
situations happening but that's just got
to be like a harrowing experience all
the way around yeah to the end
thanks for bringing it
into that shipment container
thanks for bringing us i feel like you
might be the review killer the way we're
doing this podcast
we're having a nice time talking about
serial killers yeah philip [ __ ] gets
a notification from amazon prime and
he's like oh my package is here and he's
like hey guys got my chains i tried to
go lift driving serial killers and i had
a hard time doing it people are
vulnerable especially if they don't have
enough money you can get them anyone to
do anything for 15 bucks an hour just be
like hey come to my house that's what i
make fifteen dollars now i'll read y'all
some of his recordings right every day
why you don't wanna hear him
it doesn't seem like a good time how did
you find here's one for a shovel
keep in the car for when you have to
hide bodies and you left the full-size
shovel at home it does not come with a
[ __ ] and you left the full size and he
says does not come with a [ __ ] he
killed a [ __ ] with a shovel
it's just not really
buried a [ __ ] i guess that's a pretty
shallow ground i think that's a
five-star review what's up huns
yeah it's a five-star i think the serial
killers have bad senses of humor they're
like doesn't come with a [ __ ] just the
fact that you mention a [ __ ] makes it
funny oh yeah well it's like it's it's a
mini shovel in case you leave the oh so
that kind of it kind of has some
he's a mini shuffle it's a mini shovel
with so he's like doesn't come with a
[ __ ] you think he may be i don't know
that's a good joke do you think like
killing a [ __ ] like really counts or
it's a it's a point three think about a
child
here's one for
a master lock five stars works great
also if someone talks back go old school
on them by putting this in a sock and
beating them they will not appreciate
the hardened steel like you will
works great on a shipping container
so he was leaving um
were any of these products given like a
four star or a three star
[Music]
yeah he's just like you know what i had
a little i'm starting everything you
think he went
do you think he gets any computer time
when he went back and he was like didn't
work that well doesn't hold up to us all
the fbi can cut right through this you
think they let them like uh review the
product you got caught on you know hey
guys so they found my ping um
turns on me going away for a while
word
oh
um we'll send you amazon packages
hmm
i think killers i think serial killing
is like fascinating to me can you get
amazon in prison
no they got the commissary yeah i mean
we spent so much time being nice to
people we're like what if we just went
off and treated people exactly how i
wanted to treat them right
the way you said it makes it seem like
you're fine with it you almost feel like
it i understand it i think it's it's you
understand
i think it's the way that the world
should be it doesn't need to be done but
i think it's completely understandable
it's an ancient act right because you
always have a backstory
his mother beat him every day and
flogged him and then when he went over
to his grandmother's house
his grandmother beat him because he
found out that his mom had something to
beat him for and then you're like yeah
and then he grew up and he killed a
bunch of people right well yeah he
killed multiple and he killed a bunch of
people who looked like his grandma and
mother isn't that weird that he did that
what that husband looked like his
grandmother and mother right yeah i
brought the btk killer on yesterday's
podcast but i think someone turned it
into a burger king
like a whole burger king segment because
of it that's another strange one
he ends up eluding or like keeping away
from the cops for 13 years and then he
ends up teasing the media by sending in
a floppy disk
and then the file name on the floppy
disk is the church he works at and he's
caught like that
technology bust them
immediately damn bro i should stop
leaving my files like that he was good
for 13 years he just he's hockey he's
great to be an [ __ ] like he was a
true monster
really bad 13 years ago i just don't
know what i'll do
it just doesn't make any sense
i think that's part of it part of being
the series like the pain that you put
someone in it's just like how can you
put someone through that much pain
it's insane yeah yeah i mean we have the
ability to feel other people's pain
which is usually used to avoid pain in
other people but that can also be used
to torture people in ways that animals
can't
yeah
did you see that black mirror about the
guy who had the helmet where you could
feel the other people's pain you're
talking about a black museum right yeah
the doctor he wasn't black though
but uh
black museums are pretty boring black
museum dude where she's like what's this
pretty much every time
every
every
every plaque starts with this
every plaque starts with this bee
this be a big bone
oh [ __ ]
world star
do you have headphones on are you
walking around with them
put that down you plug it into the wall
you press the button and it's [ __ ]
iced tea
it's a
it's a
fossilized chicken fried chicken
wow yeah
great riley
this shit's mad old
this is the first watermelon yeah no
date on any of these about 450 years old
no damn
yeah we're gonna stop this this actually
has to be deleted now
i think so well in that case let's show
this tool let's show this to a black
person and see what this he said in that
case get the syringe out
let's do it right
oh does it have to be deleted now
no it doesn't i think we said black
museum it was all right you can feel it
it was kind of not
it was uh kind of not a podcast for a
while
what yeah riley hated it no i didn't
wants us to delete it
uh
so what about the pain helmet
oh yeah so he would like go around
killing people and he would absorb their
pain like it'd be like
like like he's like dying he would just
like feel
he was like addicted how did he look
again how did he look like an addiction
show what he looked to see again
that's funny because usually you try to
avoid pain but this guy apparently for
some reason do they explain why he lies
no yeah he gets the feeling of them
dying right
he hated him why doesn't he just torture
himself no he just he did it so much and
then he was just like needed more like
he was addicted to the pain that's so
depressing and negative and pessimistic
if you had that helmet you use that to
find pleasure you'd go around [ __ ] as
many people and get twice that yeah but
he was a doctor
he was doing the opposition like feel
the injuries where the injuries are
yeah
so that's why he did it
yeah but pain is bad pleasure is good i
know but he's doing it for science
no he's doing it for pleasure
oh yeah it turned into he feels someone
addicted to the feeling of death
yeah and it just he becomes addicted to
it and i imagine it's a pretty solid
it's like so going out of your way to
tell a depressing story when you could
tell an awesome story instead we just
did the black museum
i love black i i watched what's up
leads to telling funny things black
mirror that's why i don't like black
mirror they're not trying to like
make people happy yeah they're just like
depression
yeah that's where we're heading it's
it's good film
it's like it's good cinematography you
think it's good because it's like [ __ ]
up
um yeah a little bit
to it so
do you only watch like happy things hans
i like things that tend toward happiness
maybe like dune where it's like
dude
second order sad
yeah
but there's a general positivity towards
it where he's fighting he's trying to
fight fix it but black marriage just
like the world's gonna suck
we're not gonna try to make it better
yeah i mean you can show depressing
things as long as you have hope but if
you show
just depressing it's depressed a lot of
people say hope is a nasty drug um
yeah that would make sense yes i know
obama
wrong
yeah i would think he would say crack
cocaine as an addictive drug it was like
war on drugs how about this hope for
everybody
oh can i get a little bit of hope can i
get some hope money i need more hope in
my monitors
yeah i got some hope we can smoke
i think we should end it i don't hope we
should smoke
well i hope they enjoyed it
i don't know dude that was all over the
place goodbye
i'm saying depressing things bye
holy [ __ ] dude we're just like in like a
podcast world
um
[Music]
no way let me see
i [ __ ] lost it damn bro how did you
lose that at jordan's house i lost it
[Music]
that sucks right he stole that [ __ ] you
think he did
jordan does he have any
videos i bought this [ __ ] from him
well now hopefully he finds it and gives
it back to you
that's what i told them no
i do
two one of them was like 9.5
that sucks it sounds like you lost
really good lead
that [ __ ] felt really bad that feels
great out here right now
yeah because last time we were kind of
get close
i'm not worried about getting enough to
show up
yeah this shows up
i mean i guess you're just making
conversations